I think that's Ryan heard and Mara and
she looks so cute okay there's an ad
I really good chemists and count us in
three two good evening Millennials we
are live at the cma red carpet the
morning toast you are either watching us
on our youtube channel very well-known
extremely famous or ex very well-known
and extremely famous a little bit more
well known a few if you ask me um if you
are an Xfinity customer make sure to
grab your little remote and be like yo
remote let me see the morning toast CMA
Awards and our faces will pop right up
it's it's a pretty magical it's a
beautiful thing so the carpet is gun
started about 30 minutes ago we're gonna
cut to some of the feeds Maren Mars just
survived looking like Lady gaga
but like country Lady gaga yeehaw gaga
she is looking beautiful in bloom we are
so excited we are so excited to be here
just like this always the best night of
the year and it's a kind of daunting
it's like we need to do a two and a half
hour livestream and then it's gonna be
over but it goes by like this because we
are country music's biggest fans on this
just country music's biggest night and
it is such an honor to be here it's only
fitting that we are here you know are
going to be talking to all of your
favorite country music stars asking them
all the questions that you really want
to know and the questions like they
might not want to answer but we're gonna
get to like Luke Holmes will you marry
me right and it's like I think he's
taken but you never know any of it
happen at the CMA let's talk a little
bit cuz there's so many couples in CMA I
feel like country music is such a fun
like fandom to be a part of because
there's so many couples and there's some
couples so many like country artists a
to each other and they make music
together bright lights too many people
to ship you know right so I would say
right now I'm definitely shipping on
Niko Hawking and Luke Holmes I'm
shipping here so much with jealousy if I
didn't love her so much because like I
want to be here but at the same time
she's the best like she should be it's
like I'm so happy for Luke that he has
her it's so true like then also like the
lanes oh yeah see Chris Lane and Lauren
Lane she changed her Instagram yeah at
Lauren Lane from Laura Bush now we're
gonna see them here they were looking
super cute last night at the BMI Awards
like so chic so chic it's so exciting
you never know who's gonna roll through
it because there's also celebrity
presenters like it's just anything had
happened at the morning to us at the CMA
I heard Reese with her spoon she will be
here she's gonna bring her spoon
maybe she'll walk right past us and you
guys can see her that way yeah so we
really exciting position because while
one would suspect that we have a bad
position and and you know we might it's
you're not interesting to see that we're
at the exit so it's like everyone has to
walk by us before leaving so yes you one
could look at the glass half-empty and
be like oh you're at the end but one
could look at the glass half-full and
say that's just the beginning of the CMA
Awards it's just the beginning no one is
allowed to leave this place without
walking past house we have someone here
we are gonna get to see everyone you
want to know leave a comment on our
YouTube stream who you want to see I
mean the names are so big we got Dolly
Parton here we got Reba we got Carrie
Underwood's honestly it's a female heavy
night at the CMA Awards and that's why
the morning toast is here because we're
a female heavy show yes so it's the 53rd
annual CMA Awards which is a lot and
we've been here for three of them so
we're at the fiftieth the 54 oh no 51st
52nd and 53rd in our strong suit no
that's why we're your music is we have
somebody coming I'm very excited hi it's
gonna be such a great time you guys I
just really am feeling like I'm already
sweating like the chub-rub is already
very much in full effect and I think
that that is exciting you know that's
just indicative of the kind of net we're
gonna have right and so let's get
started
you know I just love that we have like
so much you know like it's like live
television it's just like there's so
much happening it's like we're gonna be
on like we know what's goin on but we
don't we're just gonna chat with pretty
much anyone you know yeah anyone who
will talk to us like let's have a
conversation oh yeah so there isn't we
usually have a full bar no we were
yelled at and told because we're in
Music City Center this year we are not
allowed to have alcohol so this is very
much a prong totally agree next year
we're riding yeah yeah I don't like that
we'll do it outside next time big time
how are you feeling tonight you look
dapper good I'm gonna eat this
sweetheart that's a big speech that's
interesting because there's like some
premium candy here and it's sweeter
finally yeah I realize you're giving
worms oh my god
I'm so good now thank y'all we try to
make it fun here you know yeah
give you some energy sugar hi y'all
y'all having fun Nashville we live for
Nashville do you live here I do I live
in East Nashville about 10 minutes east
of here so he's a crazy to be here at
the CMA Awards Nashville's biggest night
what's so awesome I remember moving here
watching it going to like some of the
after parties and stuff but just it's
awesome a me and
now I got two gummy worms and that's
you're good to go
absolutely but I don't you know you
don't even dare dream of doing things
like this when we're kind of thinking
about it and so cool well it's so cool
to be here the environment is it's
electric much like your suit which I am
loving all know who are you wearing I
have no clue okay okay oh actually hold
on we're fine now there's one way to
find out wait it is listed taylor taylor
and Lucchese boots of course got to keep
the rattlesnakes going there's a ton of
crazy performances tonight we got Kacey
Musgraves
and Willie Nelson who are you looking
forward to someone you've never seen
perform before well I've seen her
perform before but she's my absolute
favorite ever I cannot wait to see
Halsey oh yeah performing Elam of the
Xfinity live show it's gonna be a treat
oh she's my favorite artist ever Wow I
saw her two years ago I got a meter and
I was like shaking dream collab shakin
in your boots Oh seriously that would be
cool could you imagine her me my round
snake moods in that suit I could see it
I do son I think Halsey will like that
suit maybe if I was wearing my bass
first job says she'd be like pass
probably about like no she seems like a
Bass Pro Shop kind of gal odette yeah
definitely for sure she loves a good
boat yacht moment exactly exactly but
I'm up for that
yeah Willie and Kacey Musgraves I mean
come on that's me all we hope you've a
good time tonight party have a drink
this is the morning toast we want to
know will you toast into tonight man I'm
toasting to country damn music and
female country music ooh great answer
and three more gummy worms is what I'm
really toasting to what you gotta do to
survive Travis yeah nice to meet you
we'll be open all night what a cutie so
who that was you want to know that was
Travis tanning he is currently a top 40
single called after a few and now we
have Kylie Morgan joining us hello looks
so beautiful you look so beautiful
we're kind of matching like with our
little like dresses and like your hue
really ties it all together for the
three of us okay we'll grab you a
microphone and then you can just join us
remix two and a half hours are you doing
anything for the next two and half hours
so how do you feeling is this your first
CMA Awards this is my first CMA Awards
to walk the red carpet I've actually
been a CMA member since I was 15 and I
have been coming to the awards I skipped
the whole high school thing so like the
CMA Awards were kind of my prom every
who needs high school school is for
Falls so your first time walking the red
carpet what what is it like I mean I've
never you know walked her red carpet
I've just kind of stood here what's your
go-to pose yeah oh good struggling with
that tonight I'm not gonna lie I think
it's just the hand on the hip yeah I
feel like it's a power pose and you're
like this is me this is very slick I'm
into it all right we got a ton of
performances tonight I'm personally
really jazz oh we like your earrings too
you've got two going on girl I'm really
jazzed about Kacey Musgraves she's the
queen of mine also Luke combs who are
you looking forward to just seeing for
the first time I think I've never seen
Casey actually up close and personal
I've met her many times we'll be putting
out which is hilarious but I've actually
never jealous I just named dropped all
the time here at the morning toast no
but I was so excited to see her she's
such an icon and just doing music in a
different way and a different format has
been incredible to watch agreed well you
look stunning this is the morning toast
before we let you go
what are you tossing to tonight I'm
toasting to new opportunities and
staying in the moment and loving the
journey wow what a great answer I
usually learn to stay in the moment and
living for the journey more they journey
down the red carpet exactly have a great
time tonight Congrats you look so
beautiful
bye nice to meet you what a cutie what
fun well I'm really sweating now like
you can tell the night has begun when
the sweat starts to like dripping down
my neck yep these pits these pits are
nice and moist we've got another guest
yes yes awesome explain time integration
behind the ball ty I just love bolos man
is it a bolo its bolo you never saw that
episode of Wizards of Waverly Place are
you always herds of Waverly Place fan
I'm a Selena Gomez fan all the same so
exciting isn't it
it's unreal oh man Garth Brooks walked
by me like 10 minutes ago like I just
shook trying to be cold just Brooks it's
so hard to be cool don't you agree
like with these performances coming up
man I can't wait yeah but don't you feel
like country music it's like they care
less about being cool like everyone's
very much more down to earth than any
kind of like pop music award show yeah
yeah I mean I moved I moved here from
San Diego so I've done the LA scene a
lot and I love it there but like I can't
go to a bar or a club with jeans on I
can't hear ya we love jeans here at the
morning toast not gonna lie you look so
comfortable yeah oh thanks for calling
me out I am wearing slippers
I just can't yes I am an elegant [ __ ]
yes I am gasps okay so this is the
morning toast before we let you go we
want to know what are you tossing to
tonight I'm toasting to women in country
music and Dolly Parton forgetting me
here oh my god that seems to be very
popular answer tonight and that's a
great vibe to have you know yes yeah
well thank you so much it was so nice to
meet you thank you so much guys you too
have a great night
so exciting so exciting so warm unclear
that was but she was so Spanish she was
so sweet mate look forward to like
catching up with me her work that's what
it is it's like at the beginning of the
red carpet it's always do you know the
smaller artist and then like year year
and year goes by like they're bigger and
bigger and bigger and then you're seeing
them at like seven o'clock when they
were here for 45 you know right it's
kind of cool to watch people grow up the
genisis Regenesis yeah
so yeah here's just an update still
sweating yep but having so much on all
right I think it's only gonna get worse
on this wedding front but you know what
maybe that'll give us just like a glow
enhance our highlighter and you'll see
the genesis of our bodily fluids so
things are swarming down we are gonna
cut to the red carpet feed let us see
what's going on and we will be back in a
few moments
Hey I think we did cut are we are we lie
are we
hello everyone we are back feeling very
excited we wanted to say revin up on the
red carpet it really are but we wanted
to take a quick second to say we wanted
to take a second to say hi to all of our
fans watching live on Xfinity right now
for the first time ever our red carpet
coverage is streaming directly through
their entertainment platform Xfinity x1
not only can you use x1 to stream
YouTube and Netflix but it's finiti
delivers the fastest internet and best
in-home Wi-Fi with Xfinity x5 and if you
need to internet to watch the morning
toast every day then you better get with
excited it sounds like you watch the
morning host every day because it's
pertinent to the situation and if you
would like to learn more about how to do
that go to ex Finn TV slash toast
that's x-fi n dot TV slash toast and
your life is gonna change forever
because you'll be able to watch a
morning toast unbeatable internet speed
sign on get premium content and
unbeatable internet speeds here's one
thing about the CMAs before we get our
next guests like the carpet starts off
slow but then in the words of Luke
reason when it rains it pours and now
you're about to talk to you the CMA
kickstart artist it is Everett hello
Everett join us hi welcome to morning
toast you guys look great thank you very
much can we can we learn a little bit
more about these outfits the inspiration
the designer who are you airing Taylor
and honestly the looks off the charts
we are stylist the inside of this jacket
I think is just as cool as the outside
we're three for three on twisted Taylor
so a night to tell big night credible I
mean a little out-of-body experience
going on right now but it's beautiful we
feel like we're a small part of this
amazing family they call country music
it's awesome so you guys are the CMA
kickstart artists can you explain to
everyone what that means yeah there are
plenty of applicants I think we heard
like 70s all over the US and I think
abroad but like they choose they whittle
it down to three artists or bands and
we're a duo but we're just super honored
and humbled to be chosen by the
industry's best of the best like they
they thought we were good enough to be
in the group it's a huge deal and
there's an award tonight for our best
duo of the year whoo you guys forgot
your money on we got Florida Georgia
line Maddie and Tay
yeah they're buddies of ours it's been a
great year for brothers Osborne
they've just been silently like
releasing bangers you know like not
really no one's no one's making a big
deal of it but silently they're killing
it you know a new album is so great
musically lyrically yeah it's a work of
art and there's great people yes we love
a family duo yes we are the sisters
house right here so okay so we hope you
guys have a good time tonight before we
let you go this is the morning toast we
have to know what you were toasting to
tonight we're toasting to a fun year
this has been a rollercoaster year and
this is definitely a highlight so that's
what we'll be posting time I'm toasting
to my wife and I having a babysitter
tonight baby you're getting an exclusive
baby announcement you toasted enough
about the baby already a year older
so nice to meet you guys have a good
night good luck Congrats
you just award how did we become the CM
a kickstart I know she's the senior
kickstart host I wish there was a CMA
red carpet award for like people with no
zest and vert and the best candy
selection like right but then we also
talked about like how low-key annoying
aside we don't have alcohol last year
like people didn't know who we were but
they just like we're drawn to us because
we had alcohol and now that's been
stripped from us I mean it's like rely
on our towns to get us places which is
just so hard it's nowhere but I think
that we can do it we also have candy
which is a good crud yes let's go
through let me give you a little tour of
my candy station over here
we have a classic skittles even though
technically they're not kosher I think a
lot of people will be fine with that
then we have the swedish fish you know a
little bit a little bit crazy you know I
know it's crazy to have a fish at the
red carpet it's honest a little smelly
yes for the pescetarians out there like
to have some dish fish for the Swizz
'yes that is a joke from less your CMA
Awards like if you haven't watched that
stream it was pretty premium like go
check it out I think that might be like
the most nice joke of all time
no no literally one person also if
you're just watching this on Xfinity I'm
no clue who we are like you probably
just turned it up okay but we have to
talk about something that happened last
year and we need to make sure I'm
nothing but I remember this guy Caleb he
was I think the second runner-up on
American Idol that year he was at the
CMA Awards and he literally inspired
like the most hilarious joke to ever
happen to us because basically the award
the red carpet last year was outside and
we had all of our little candies again
we had unwrapped chocolate candies kind
of like this and before he left he took
a couple and put him in his coat pocket
and if you later literally so hot he
took unwrapped chocolates and he was
talking about how like his mom got him
the suit and like we would
like so worried about him the whole time
like thinking about those warm
chocolates melting in his mom soon you
know that they melted he'd like to leave
already sweaty he like it was so much
like here for the whole night right no
it was just like we couldn't something
about him so now we need to talk to him
this year like is he wearing same suit a
different suit is my life to City now
like year later how long did he think to
get the same one year later like is a
stain still there but maybe doesn't even
know like oh my god maybe he threw the
suit in the wash and got everything
journey oh my god he doesn't know where
it came from he thought he was watching
me she was broken leg he thought it was
a sewage problem it was just like a
little bit chocolate left so hard I hurt
my chest also it's worth noting I've
been battling food poisoning all day but
the spirits of the CMAs that really get
you through but like just in case
anyone's worried we have pepto baby
house pepto-bismol like we have what we
need and also Campari the best chapstick
not an add just like one and everyone to
now just wanted everyone to know also
you have been battling food poisoning my
super 4 here that you are by the way
it's I this is literally like the Civil
War and like I'm in a battle but like
there's no better time to have food
poisoning like first snack see how you
haven't eaten the thing snatched she is
this snatchler yeah new episode up
tienen podcast what's good so in case
you're just tuning in and you're like
who are these girls
we were hosted the morning toast a very
popular morning show we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
any all morning show I'm going to
everyone of all ages we're not HSN at
all we Jackie's a theory that shark tank
is Aegis and honestly the more I hear
about it like I kind of agree also we're
sisters my name is Claudia this is
Jackie hey Jackie
um I know a lot of you guys watching on
our YouTube channel are big fans of the
morning toast we love you we see you hi
toasters how are you what's good counts
and if you're new you're watching on
Xfinity you just want to watch a CMA
Awards and then like these two girls
popped up
hi we're excited to meet you feel free
to watch us every day Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube our teaching account is
youtube.com slash morning toast and
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it
Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio
iHeartRadio cashbox you know all the
places just search the morning to us if
you like what you see leave a review
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are we will greatly appreciate it
definitely on the smarts like that's
really appreciate it so it's definitely
like a slow moment it's like a low here
yes but we do momen I just want to take
it all in you know yeah by the way guys
it's such an exciting night for us like
literally we live 364 days for one day
of the year if I had to ask you don't
look at your phone how long you think
we've been live what would you guess
25 minutes better okay I have a good
vomiter for time now um my barometer for
time is like my chub-rub and now it's
like you would think we'd be in here for
20 minutes just based on my chub rub
alone but it's actually only been 25
usually my feet are a good barometer for
time but I'm wearing a nice kitten heel
tonight so I think I'm gonna I'm in the
last long
okay let's go through some of the
nominations shall we oh yeah okay I
think I have a list of them somewhere I
would love to hear your thoughts where
do we have the nominations darling we
have them somewhere well I know there's
a rattle off the ones off the top of my
head well looking you know the most
controversial nominations I'd like to
talk about the snubs oh my god combs for
Entertainer of the Year like where's
that nomination by the way he entertains
so many people every year every it's
like it's an abomination I'm so sick and
did you see him at stagecoach like I'm
so sick of the same people being
nominated like the bias it's almost as
bad as Shark Tank yeah
Oh a really beautiful woman is coming
like I wonder who it is Parker there's
beautiful woman coming okay let's talk
about entertainer of the year it's very
controversial because finally a woman is
nominated by Carrie Underwood and then
she's with four other great people but
who are nominated literally every year
it's Garth Brooks Eric Church Chris
Stapleton Carrie Underwood and Keith
Urban honestly if it can't be Carrie
Underwood which it should be I'm kind of
here for Keith Urban because he truly
entertains every year yeah I'm inspired
who do I have my money on I probably
Chris Stapleton cuz he wins everything
yeah but he's been very quiet because I
feel like he's like feels guilty he's
like want to give someone else a change
but no this is very much a year of the
women into music so container of the
year for country music was honestly
Kacey Musgraves if I'm being honest no
she was not only the Entertainer she was
like the representative right like she
took country music to all new heights
she took the country music to Kendall
Jenner's birthday party so daddy's never
gone before it's never gone there before
angry I am oh my god curse is coming she
looked so beautiful shows with her new
husband Michael right let's talk about
her because she's also nominated for a
new artist I was just like a really
procedure so prestigious I hope she win
if you talk to any music artist in the
industry about Carly Pierce you know
they say about her they say she's
literally the hardest working woman in
country music
she's the nicest and I'm so happy for
cuz she just got married and she's with
Michael ray rain Oh shucks okay we're
gonna talk to them but so new artists of
the years Kody chomps Johnson is a
nominate Midland they're not so new
Carly Barse formally pronounced Pierce
but Barstow star you know why Ashley
McBride and Morgan Wallen who's kind of
a little too new would you know any I
don't know
they make these nominations not gonna
lie but I'm not gonna question it too
much because we're happy to be here yeah
also like would you consider lil nas ex
to be like a potential nominee for Best
new country artist I think you need more
than one country song and you know I
think that's super fair but Morgan
Rollins snuck his way that's true he's
also too he has risky glasses whiskey
could use some we so we're really hoping
and praying that Diplo's here tonight we
have my know like reason to believe that
he is other than he's like also I don't
think he's in the booklet let me check
on that I have the book that we have the
booklet ooh I'd love to see this booklet
do a little research it's alphabetical
do you think it's Thomas or Diplo oh I
think it's Diplo okay under Thomas
Wesley let's see Thomas Wesley there's
no way I'm God's green diddly Dahlia so
thank goodness Wesley had that is his
real name and that's his country name
but like his Instagram picture lo Shan
mcanally is coming now you're talking
about I'm desperate to talk to him he is
a one of the judges I guess they're
called on song land no Diplo Wow
very sad they're disappointing very
unfair I have a lot of intentions to ask
a lot of people about song land tonight
because I'm obsessed with it people are
cheering whoo everyone's cheering for
Carly piercing she's gonna win Best New
Artist and honestly I don't disagree I
don't disagree either I think and you
know what tonight is really about women
in country music that's what I'm saying
finally like and I think that Carly
Parks could take home the big W yeah
that would be actually huge for her
perform at CMA Awards on the main stage
which is like really a big deal and then
she also got cut into the CMA ABC
livestream telecast whatever a few
months later wasn't live it was a
telecast but it was really big deal so I
feel like she's kind of like the heart
and soul of the CMA Awards this year and
I think that thing could be really good
for her yeah it's good stuff I'm pulling
for her Carly Parks man Carly
[ __ ] I hope she like doesn't
like that we call her that no I think
that she loves that we have like an
inside joke but let's ask her about it
when she comes here yeah she's a lot
going on she just got married she had a
name change from Carly Pierce to Carly
parce Rae and she also has a new song
that is a [ __ ] banger it's a duet
Suzy Brice oh yes mm-hmm it's very good
at its getting a lot of radio play yeah
and we live in New York and there's not
a lot there's one country radio station
and they're always playing that damn
song it's called I hope you're happy now
I just like looked into it because it's
really so good and also fun fact Luke
owns art on it so I just want to talk to
her about how to carry and that's great
thanks for reminding me like we wrote
down so many things to talk about it's
like hard when we are like some people
here it's like they come from LA you
know they won't have that little thing
in their ear and know what they don't
really know we're truly country music's
biggest fans and this is country music's
biggest night so we have so many things
we want to talk to people about it's
actually like borderline overwhelming
with like I'm so afraid when I talked to
Luke Collins later like and I'm so
afraid I still just talk to him about
like he's playing his first stadium tour
he's almost getting married like he just
had to I'm like there's so much like so
much I'm gonna hear a creep point
factoid yes Luke Holmes's new album it's
been like such a big part of you look so
good it's been less than weeks under my
minute that's crazy
it's been less for me because I was in
Morocco and I didn't have a chance
listen to it so it's been like four days
for me oh wow no I know it's like a head
shot it's so good I can't wait to talk
to him about it
Carly Parsons moving slowly down the
carpet but you know she could take her
time she's the queen of country music
it's a good let's take a break let's
show you guys some of the live stream we
will be back thank you guys for watching
stay tuned
you
used to have a scotch cartoon okay we
are back with kind of a power couple and
I think what makes them so powerful is
that Robin here as a toaster you guys
guys introduce yourselves you both just
like gave yourselves amazing intros
because you are quite accomplished
totally yes my name is Renee Blair and
this is Jordan Smith yeah for God's
country Wow honestly such a good song
it's definitely gonna win do you need me
to sing a little snippet yeah it goes
like this we work is it working with
Blake Shelton well I mean I didn't
really we wrote the song without him but
just having him cut it was amazing
amazing great for the bank you know
absolutely watch a show Nashville yes
because it's very much like that that's
the vibe and it's just so exciting to
have such a big like star cut your song
yeah it's uh yeah changing for sure are
you from Nashville either of you know
I'm from Minnesota I'm from st. Louis
wow that's so cute well you guys know
well you know this is the morning show
so before we leave we know you guys are
busy you got a lot to do
what are you tossing to tonight just
being nominated and being here I've been
to the awards a few times but nothing
like the red carpet in this so I think
just I don't know if he likes this joke
but I was joking earlier that most
little girls dream of their wedding day
and I've always thought of my first
Grammy or CMA red carpet
same-sex everything up is it everything
you dreamed of yes I feel like you look
stunning
you look stunning you both look so good
I'm great Jules so I could not be
happier so nice to meet you guys thank
you so much good luck so much fun on the
line for you all of them everything
except sweethearts honestly so
interesting choice okay where do you
live you know we're new york-based new
you are a couple of New York's teens
are we so guy still alive we never end
the live stream never ends
this is a typical meme like this is the
Mo's me bang I was like - she knew her
live no I did it but anyways I just you
guys are amazing and I'd love to come
podcasting yes oh my god totally come
thrills women in countries because women
in country that's so [ __ ] rude I just
like it's my fault like I can't remember
people's it was like honestly impressed
that he remembered her name you know
because and just obviously you want to
know why actually she said her name was
Rene Blair and then I was thinking of
robbing Blair the artist from New York
was getting very famous so the name
Robin was just stuck in my head also I
know we cut before we cut before and we
said we were going to meet at the Carly
part but she disappeared so that she's
television so maybe we'll catch her at
the end of her yeah but um she's out but
we've got Carrie Gabby Barrett and Kaede
from American Idol they are engaged and
I think they actually just come here
yeah I think so too
I'm sure to hear all about you know a
couple young married couples just like
us you know I guess I'm sure some are
snitches watching like drooling and just
want to say hey snitch we miss you I
just like I can't believe Robin died
maybe she didn't hear you because I
think that oh we've got cabbage Garret
you guys we go - angel you're looking
pretty wearing Sherri Hill oh we love a
Sherri Hill moment here at the Morty
toes so I don't know if you know this
but we have a sister and she's your
number one fan I think you might know
this because every time we interview you
we tell you this okay we attacked you at
CMA Awards being like will you make a
video for our sister her name is Margo
she loves you so much let her go thank
you for being a fan she really is you're
wonderful
so you guys just got married right yeah
what's it like wonderful right it's nice
and we used to live together now yes
good that's amazing where'd you guys get
married we got married in garrison Texas
he's from there
so this is your guys's second or third
CMA Awards how crazy is that like Zack
you went on the show when your life to
change right now if you guys don't know
Kate gating Kade and Gabby we're both on
American Idol you both went extremely
far and now you're out here you just
went on tour with Chris Lane right I'm
on tour you're still on tour through
December
do you love Lauren Lane yes she's a very
funny character I didn't you don't know
that about somebody who you made them
and you know she we love you they're
really funny and they always bring their
dog in the back who color and he's funny
too parents so so many people perform it
tonight I know we're both really excited
about Kacey Musgraves Luke um so you
guys looking forward to um I'm gonna say
Chris Stapleton I love Chris a what he
does - oh I'm just sad to see the
Osborne brothers running around we love
them - we love everyone it's gonna be
such a great show okay so before we let
you go we know you're busy this is the
morning toast what do you guys toasting
to tonight we used to have alcohol here
and then we got in trouble now Music
City Center you can have alcohol but if
you did have alcohol what would you make
a toast to you a sparkling cider
yes we love that well Congrats have fun
you guys a grade love the outfit 0:04
you enjoy it's not spiked with anything
but a good time thank you bye guys they
should meet you so I love it like Chuck
okay
also while we were down I get like a
complex about everything but did you
find she didn't know I think like she's
annoying she and she probably remembers
us and it's just like we attacked it and
I'm pretty sure we made her sing snitch
on the toast
we did so I understand you know what but
we do it for the snitch because we love
her while we were in town before Luke
combs
and Nico Hawking arrived on the carpet
and they just looks like the [ __ ]
snatchler I just wanna let you know we
have gotten confirmation from pretty
much everyone on his team that they will
be stopping by because you know we're in
saying and that's literally why we flew
down here and we literally spent all
this money just to meet Luke Holmes and
I'm fine with that so if they're coming
don't worry Oh Carrie Underwood has
arrived she's looking stunning a hostess
with the mostess we love a good home
he's no tied with someone else for the
hosts the person whose hosts closely at
most for the person who's hosted the
CMAs the most amount of times and I
think I believe it's Vince Gail is this
someone else we talk about the shade
about how like her and Brad Paisley
we're pretty much together every year
high-stake duo and now they just like
drop red Paisley I think it more has to
do with like the vibe of it being like
women in country being the theme of this
year's awards but it's honest today like
one Reba McEntire and another Dolly
Parton over by placing anyway also he
like is now in those nation my
commercials and I just feel like he's
too busy he's making that nationwide
money like hosting is really freaking
hard did you feel my call like I know
the song working nine to five has been
famous forever but you feel like it got
more famous in the last five months yes
because of dumpling yeah but also
because it was on a very popular tik-tok
have you seen it of the kid getting out
of bed on his hands and like his whole
body's upside down no and a breakup that
and then it gets in the shower like I
think that's why oh that's interesting I
think it also was maybe dumpling and
also Dolly Parton just assuming like
these iconic renditions with like other
people my warmed with Miley and Kayne
Marin and so they're just like
introducing this wonderful music to a
whole new demographic and I think it's
an incredible time um in case some
people are just tuning in we're getting
a lot of questions about how why this
year for the third year we are not
having alcohol for the first and second
year we had a huge bar cart everyone's
taking shots with us it was so much fun
we literally bought like this is what
our bar cart we bought a full you know
we got a stocked chef's top shelf like
we literally clear out the liquor store
and we get here today and they say
because for the first two you know
actually you know for the first year
this is the red carpets inside at the
Music City Center usually it's outside
on the street near Bridgestone Arena
they have rules here where you're not
allowed of alcohol so this is very much
a prop bottle of champagne we're not
going to open it and we can't be
offering people anyhow qahal so we're
just gonna be giving them candy yeah but
you know what the payoff is that we are
inside we didn't have to walk outside as
much as we did last year yeah in the
rain so like I'm happy for the tempo
Kerr hamburger temperature control the
temperature control meet you okay let's
get back to some of the nominations
because I know we didn't finish any I
really wanted to hear
you're gonna want to be outraged again
let's talk about male vocalist of the
year here your nominees
Dierks Bentley the nominees are Dierks
Bentley 11 Derrick's Luke combs
obviously is going to win Thomas Rhett
Chris Stapleton and Keith Urban even if
I wasn't like Luke Holmes actual number
one fan I just think like totally
nonpartisan like you just you have to
say Luke Holmes his answer no cuz he is
living in a different year unless you
have some time travelers right in the
knob in the Academy you think about it
like totally analytically it's the Time
Traveler's Wife is in the Academy's a
male he is a vocalist and he's vocalized
this year I see she's got a shoo-in he's
a shoo-in I mean there's no way he
couldn't win okay let's keep going
Oh album of the year you know I want to
talk about this because I don't really
feel like any of these albums were the
album of the year ready okay Center
Point Road which it was pretty good
snitch enjoyed he did cry pretty Carrie
Underwood
that was my enjoyed it but I don't think
it was the album of the year do you know
what I mean
yeah I like I don't know a lot of other
people that enjoyed it
dan + Shay dan + Shay oh I'm going down
and Jayden and Chester man Eric Church
he is really well-respected yeah and
girl Maren Morris girl by Mary Morris is
such a good [ __ ] album just here and
she's pregnant with a boy like it's too
much you know it's it's part it's way
too much um but I think I may go Daniel
Jaden and Shay yeah we should which
album is them together that's band's
second album ever no it's the third
because they did like nothing like you
either they would call it dan + Shay if
it's not if it's not Danny J you know I
mean yeah like dan + Shay it's like your
first album was always called like
yourself like Taylor Swift self so made
albums the first one self-titled I mean
so it's kind of weird that the third
their third album would be
self-titled you know I guess they're
just keeping us on our toes you know
Carly Parks has returned and we would
love to chat with her um she looks just
beautiful I feel like she's really
becoming the Kaiser okay we've laid eyes
on cars
okay she's she knows she's young I can
relax now like literally if I want to
talk to us
our sound the toast but I'm both parts
on the toast parts on the toast put on
bone you know spread that parse all over
my toast yeah someone get mad somebody
get this girl a knife there always comes
a moment on the carpet like there's not
a lot going on it like we really just
need to like talk out of our ass
remember two seconds ago when I was
talking all about like self titled self
titled like Taylor Swift like the third
column like self titled
like Genesis okay like you can't make me
laugh at her because a seam is gonna
open up I just want to say I'm watching
the live stream here and I have to
really just be very grateful to everyone
who's not commenting on the fact that I
have worn this dress before like yes I
did wear to Jackson Brittany's wedding
yes shockingly it still fits me and I'm
sorry I was in Morocco for a week and I
just like to prioritize getting a
Britney trust like my sister who's
looking like [ __ ] Romeo Michelle at
their high school reunion totally that
was my inspiration for tonight but this
is actually the first time that I've
gotten a new dress for the CMA Awards I
feel like you're always so proactive and
like you know to dress for the occasion
whereas I just wear something I had last
year was the year of my arm oh right and
like nothing nothing could take away
from the arm at the 15-second hammer
time on the CMA Awards
I showed an arm I wore a one-arm
jumpsuit and if you know me maybe you
don't you're watching on Xfinity you've
never heard of me but I don't show my
arms I'm just like not that kind of girl
like get to know me first and I did
dinner I had recently lost like a good
amount of weight and I decided to you
know be crazy she decided to bear arms
and I bared I bared this arm so I said
do it it was very brave I thought it
wasn't that brave because I stood like
this all the time and like this arm you
never saw here's the thing you have the
right to bear arms no by the way it's
literally in the Constitution so she
just was I was eating advantage of my
rights right let's take that some candy
Oh should we do some ASM ASMR Oh
generally not and I'm pretty sure you've
been on the show before
in this capacity on the right yeah would
you like some candy yeah I'm looking at
this like gummy bears but this year
there's no there's an overall no alcohol
really yeah that's terrible
you're super tall I am love dog yeah
how's your evening going very sharp suit
who are you wearing boots brothers you
know
influence this was peaky blinders you
ever watch that show I'm hurt about but
I saw a bunch of guys dressed up his
peaky blinders for Halloween therefore I
feel like I've watched the show help
myself if you don't mind
hello I missed these things I know I
wouldn't let me do the anyone let me do
the hair let me ask you parce on the
toes can we talk about you like your
whole thing we're so hugs you're married
now
Hubbs is slowing us down and we're live
so yeah he doesn't care okay he doesn't
respect the choices fine like whatever
no he doesn't get it cuz every night
before go go for it by the way this is
the first CMA where's what you could say
my husband how does that feel we're a
couple of married [ __ ] just so we
have oh my god isn't that great you look
so beautiful would you like some candy
gratulations if you want some candy you
are nominated tonight and we are so
excited we're all pulling for you like
if anyone would give us a vote I know
yours probably parts I don't like to
jinx anything but I could just like feel
the energy and like I really want to
tell you like I think you're gonna win
but I know they say it's just an honor
to be nominated but I've never been
nominated so tell me is it an honor it
is but you still want to win of course
and I'm gonna offer best candy booth
yeah wait we take that honestly we take
sure they had shots of whiskey and
theirs now we're not allowed because
we're in Music City Center and they have
a dry rule you can't have any liquor in
here there's no that's just a prop
bottle of champagne we're not allowed to
bring any real alcohol very sad in the
whole place he's freaking out he's like
wait a minute wait weed a lot of
questions for you because I don't know
if you know but you're really talking to
Carly Parsons number-one fan and Luke
home system run fan and he wrote on your
new song with lee Brice so he has never
lived worked with him and we should
learn to like what it would be like and
it's a lot of like 90s country energy
yeah
he ate an entire fried catfish and okra
lunch of course he did while we were
writing oh my god i'ma call them out on
it later
absolutely tell him I said he ate a
bunch of Martin's barbecue Martin's
barbecue I have to tell you fry okay and
there's only one country radio station
it's 94.7 and I'm not gonna lie it's a
little sad yeah chef M yeah it's a
little staticky but I always play when
I'm in a cab or in an uber and that song
is getting so much radio play I hear it
all over the radio
Congrats it's amazing thank you let's
look with the wedding how do you feel
awful great I mean we did it we already
know I would relive it would be the time
to tell everyone we kind of have we kind
of had a morning for the wedding the day
after because it was like sad that it
went by so fast
kind of like heartbreaking that like all
our family was there then just kind of
was like gone and everybody was leaving
do you guys have someone singing at your
wedding I remember reading that
somewhere Jay go in right what did he
sing sang song called made for you for
our first day this is his first time to
ever be a wedding singer by the way he
is so great why did you choose him I
played a song I played as a show with
him for Saint Jude and he played made
for you and we were talking about a
first dance and when he played it I was
like holy crap this has to be it so I
came home the next day played it for her
and then we were playing a show together
Jake and I the next weekend and I was he
was on the bus I was like hey dude we're
gonna dance the maid for you and he was
like no way and I was like do I shoot my
shot right now like what I do and I was
like if you happen to be home it's a
Sunday you know and he was like I'm in
and he and he just he was so he was
excited as I just said as we were I
think to do it and it was awesome you
know he had to tell my mom to like stop
grooming him and I was like get out of
here publicist is got arrested before
early parts we're so happy for you
seriously like I'm telling you either
you're doin but we can't let you go
because it's the morning shows we just
want to know what you guys are toasting
to tonight life me hopefully winning and
you look so beautiful by the way how
much look so [ __ ] snatch like oh my
god her skin your boobs
starstruck I hate objectifying women but
objectively but here I go but
objectively she look great
objectively she looks great she looks
great we're gonna objectify both men and
women on the street by the way people
people opportunity objectify er we were
just like literally like in the worst
lighting for that interview I'm so
annoyed because like there was so much
just like backing up because there were
so many people and then that guy like
trying to eat us like so nice to meet
you
know so nice meeting you but like get
out talking to car like nice to meet you
what's your name I think I don't know if
it's like the rudest thing ever asking
someone their name on the red carpet
like sometimes you cheated on your name
you know what and I'm glad that he did
give us his name because we have spoken
to him before you know and by the way
he's handsome I wonder if he's a
girlfriend he's definitely on The
Bachelor soon also chase rice is
definitely coming around soon and I got
to talk to him because it's a lot of
drama with him about Harley dating an
alleged bachelor condition you're
getting a spoiler but you know I okay if
you don't want to know
close your ears no he did that I merely
dated a bad Chuck intestine then was on
the show you know they've a country
singer perform every year and he was a
performer on a date with the girl that
he used to date so obviously was all
like super contrived I think the right
word is there's a band coming and I want
to say it's lanco oh my god if it's like
oh you know I have a bone to pick yet
but by the way I'm Elanco problems
tonight
there's Lanco ultimania and one other
one that like are like four or five
dudes inland gnome inlay dresses 70s as
hell okay there's another one okay it's
location location and it's like kind of
incredibly confusing you know it's like
they always just like mix up their
members and whoever's available just
like shows up for the event is what I
heard it's a conspiracy theory that I'm
working on you know it's like there's no
porn who's the real openly it took
everyone knows it lead singer so he has
to go everywhere but the four people
behind him like it doesn't matter each
man has four people so like technically
there's 12 people there's only six
people who make up the 12 people they
just rotate yeah okay like the Beatles
yeah yeah yeah oh another conspiracy
theory we're big on those if you're just
tuning in Claudia here Jackie there's my
sister yes we are real sisters we host a
morning show called the morning toast
it's very popular I like to think so
we're here at the CMAs 53rd annual red
carpet we are here chatting with
everyone it's just getting started it's
only 5:30 we got another hour and I have
another 90 minutes and you people really
only Cana later so we're just chatting
waiting for everyone to show Allie late
I have heard Luke Combs is in the
building and him and his fiance are
looking [ __ ] stunning she's wearing a
shimmery silver dress Carrie under what
is here she is
the star that evening she's nominated
for album of the year there's just too
much in her of the year the only woman
in the category and honestly I think
that she's gonna take it all it's a
really big deal so cry pretty I guess it
came out like at the beginning of this
so it feels lighter because it feels
like I've lived with it for so long it
feels like last year but it's an
incredible album I didn't love the song
southbound but other than that okay you
have like had this quite a bone to pick
with southbound and I just want to say I
want to take a little south bound I like
that song I don't know sad man I think
it's a good something like I don't know
promise
yeah before we get some other people I
just want to interview you who are you
wearing this oh I'm wearing it's a
French brand I don't know if you've ever
heard of it you know about this and it's
very tight and it's the biggest size
they made but it's stretchy so it's got
a little gift to give is that an
offshoot of aerogel breath BAM you okay
we are I would very much like to speak
with Danielle Bradbery
what do you want to pick with her as
well no not a bone look we should stop
making people stand in the middle of us
Oh someone else crap sure okay well grab
her next okay okay oh they're taking her
away from the other girl giving them so
beautiful and precious would you like
some candy before we get started um well
maybe after okay that's all who are you
wearing let's get started um the
designer is Hamill I've worn them in the
past and they do great look stunning
thank you
there's a lot to talk to you about
because you are on the new Charlie's
Angels soundtrack and your song is
actually my favorite one out of the
whole soundtrack including that trio do
a Oh whatever that's that song well that
song was a trash so yeah what was it
like working on the soundtrack did you
work directly with ariana grande um I
wish I could say I did but cuz I'm a
huge Ari fan but I didn't
I feel like just having a song on the
same album basically her album yes I
know you worked with her oh yeah yeah
for sure
did you get to see the movie I did good
interesting
whose favorite character um I actually
loved Kristen Stewart character she like
really showed up and I know she was like
kind of a more quiet like sad girl in a
lot of yeah Bella was very dark in
Twilight she shows yeah she shows up I
love it so this is like you're not your
first time here you've been here like
four times outright I've been here like
hard times is it crazy does it get less
like exciting or you're still always
very much like pinch me ya know it's
crazy amazing yeah we got Willie Nelson
yeah Willie Nelson Dolly Parton Halsey
Halsey I forgot what I'm most excited to
say probably like Halsey I think pink is
here some of them yes I heard that she
was here as well
yeah sure I think so yeah there's I
can't pick one I don't think okay well
you know we will make yeah okay we're
you let you go cuz I'm sure everyone
wants to talk to you but before we do
here at the Morning Joe so we got to
know what are you doing to tonight yes
that seems to be the popular answer
tonight and I'm very much here for it
I'm just saying it's true yeah well now
you could take a piece of candy before
you leave and we've got M&Ms yes we tart
yeah and maybe know what we thought this
would be very nice according your purse
for later yeah yeah I need to when you
start giving out the mints because like
I know I'm always nervous about having
bad breath and like I'm sure famous
people are afraid about to write oh
absolutely yeah oh wait yes oh you don't
look like I look like I just pull a you
don't look right stop what [ __ ] you pull
a order
oh it's like a bowl I had to do a bowl
because I had to watch the lipstick
actually it's a burrito yeah that's too
messy though yeah I know that's too
messy yeah you look so great well call
me later okay
Tyler rich okay I just saw the hottest
new show there's your cutie sweetie wait
there okay
Jackie I just saw the hottest guy is
that the Rios I was looking to bury and
I couldn't even focus because I'm like
who is the male model if I thought he
was Tim Tebow for his role is just be
like hottest guy on the carpet you know
honestly like I think I think he's
nominated for hottest guy in the carpet
I think he's gonna win he's gonna pull
through it's just really exciting it's
an exciting time to be him you guys we
are going to talk to Tyler reg he has a
new song called rather be us
it is amassed over 150 million streams
very exciting we've even married he's
newly married let's talk to him about
that and he's a 20-19 pandora artist to
watch how do they come one of those
things like okay I released a song I
would like to be an artist to watch
plays yeah well someone watch me we're
watching we have a couple thousand
people on all my Xfinity folks watching
me YouTube toasters what's good is
everyone having a good time how's
everyone feeling tonight I'm feeling so
sweating butts so happy and grateful to
be here so happy so grateful kitten
heels you know what they are a little
uncomfortable but I'm powering through
those are not kitten heels
they're like two-inch what and a half
note those are not two inch and I think
two and below is what one would consider
I think Amanda hug guys getting closer
and coming who is Lehman on the hunt guy
I just know who he is
well just get will capture his interview
oh wow they're dancing they are dancing
oh wow okay he looks like Tim Tebow
that's our interview with the hot guy
thank you so much for coming sir yeah
it's really a pleasure tells me that
anytime tonight good luck you look
stunning what are you testing to you
denied it there really should be the
host ease yeah we should host them
probably still wouldn't be nominated Wow
it's depressing oh my god okay also I'm
not like nas ex is definitely coming
tonight because he kind of shook up the
country world and took it by storm I
would love to know what he's wearing
like he is such an eclectic guy and such
an eclectic dresser I would like to know
what he's wearing and who he's wearing
yeah and like who who's dating yet who
dressed him who dressed him yeah there's
like so much politics behind getting
dressed like you think like oh I'm going
to a war show let me get a dress no no
that's not how it works I mean that's
how it works for us no maybe that's how
it works at amateur hour you know hope
for us but for everyone else to take a
look to do you got a stylist you get
jewelry think I've sent it back drama hi
oh my god there's got great hair
collectively thank you I'll take you
thank you what's the maintenance like on
a Mane like that uh surprisingly low I
don't do a whole lot with it so hey guys
feeling you excited nervous what's the
vibe yeah we're pumped yeah right how
many times have you guys been here I
think this is our third time fourth time
yeah
you excited to see the night man the
opening yeah the big opening just a
little life yeah annoying yes we also
usually has alcohol here but there's a
new rule and I'm alcohol so sorry you
need to do is soak the candy and alcohol
before you get on the red carpet no one
will know about it yeah yeah okay so
before we let you go this is the morning
toast we got to know what each of you
guys are toasting to tonight I'm gonna
have any alcohol to actually toast with
so this question is like a little less
exciting than usual but still what are
you testing to I mean I feel like we got
a toast to the women of country music I
mean that's like that's what the night's
all about so we'll start there yeah
that's pretty good one yeah I'm gonna
toast to my baby girl at home I just had
a little girl at home she's taking care
of her and I can't wait to see them
later nice you got your own you know we
have a new song coming out and I'm
pretty excited about that music we got a
new single living my best life out now
oh yeah harmonize honey Oh what are you
trusting to Graham took my baby what do
you think yeah if you're wearing
something else though I don't think it
works like it's just the jacket the
fringe the tie it works it's a group
thing all right well I'll just stay in
place rings yeah so nice to meet you
guys have fun tonight I'll take that
feel free to take a goody bag or
something on your way out
yeah don't be shy don't be shy nice um I
guess I guys okay get a little stares
the end we have another angel coming by
angel so many beautiful it wasn't it
wasn't are you
I have no idea who was but Parker was
mouthing it's me and I couldn't see 1000
she said I think she said I have no idea
and then she found out 1000 I was that
lianca
was that lanco no okay that sounds about
right
definitely not like no I need to google
what they look like because I have to
talk to Lancome outside of it and it's
not like and we just ruin that interview
it doesn't Lancome Lancome gives me a
vibe but none of those guys did not give
me the vibe like that I was thinking I
don't know what they look like so it's
five guys that was before right okay
okay okay there's a guy with long black
hair yeah yeah because we gotta find
like yeah I'll kind of look more like
Jojo Tyler rich is coming up next
oh we've gone west with Kobe LA I think
we want I had to talk to her she just
like up and decided to become a country
artist and I very much respect that like
that's what I would do it starts in my
toes makes me crinkle man knows okay
a lot has happened in the last 20
minutes wanted to catch up with you guys
how are you doing where are you guys
watching and we got a bunch of you
watching on YouTube the morning toast
youtube count
we're also got a bunch of people
watching on Xfinity x1 that's so cool
that we're finally on TV like my dream
coming true dreams coming true here
tonight the CMA Awards we've got so much
candy I think it's time that I take an
M&M a cocooned worm another nice dough
from the morning toes yes
a caterpillar caterpillar yeah break
we'll cut to the red carpet stream let
you guys see the arrivals here we'll
catch you in a few cut to that
you
say what everyone three two one okay
everyone we are back welcome back to the
cma red carpet live streams at the
morning toast we are here with Colbie
Caillat and gone West very excited to
have you here we've heard a lot about
you guys
people are talking collectively as a
group is this your first CMA Awards yeah
I feel really good you know we get to
wear home bodies a lot when we're not on
the road and so to get dressed up
tonight and be coordinating these
handsome gentlemen and their suits and
just to get to come and see this
incredible show with all these amazing
performers and collaborations it's gonna
be really fun it's such a good show I
imagine it's great to watch from inside
you know we wouldn't know are you guys
excited who you excited to see all
sweaty up and close a lot of people are
saying that question about what it's
like to get dressed as a group do you
have to coordinate you send each other
pics yes you guys are definitely
coordinating but not too similar you
know in my very in time for the sequel
of frozen like one cohesive band and so
yeah we coordinated otherwise you know
one of us will roll up wearing all pink
and everybody else is in green or
something so so embarrassing let me ask
you about your hat tell me about it well
it's a tourist focally a custom hat
it actually has our logo sewn into the
Wow was it gone west hat and I'm proud
to rock it it's pretty pretty epic
honestly thank you you guys are so sweet
this the morning show so before we let
you go we have to ask you what are you
tossing to tonight I wanna hear from all
of you women celebrate women and
diversity
very good being home with family coming
up soon I couldn't agree more with what
Justin said just because I feel like
women are like the foundation of country
music so tonight's gonna be great to
celebrate them I'm just I'll do it for
music health and love I mean all of
those things they go to they go together
well but I'm just we love it well so
nice to meet you guys Congrats have fun
and keep killing it because people are
talking it's good stuck to me I okay
reminds me so much of me anymore like I
can not think of anything else that's so
crazy right like she was talking I'm
like I literally felt like I was in The
Princess Diaries I'm like stop being
mean to Prince Anne Hathaway I totally
built a her hair okay you guys Humphreys
next to us we've had them on the show
every year they're an acapella country
band then I will know like the
pentatonix I will not stop until we get
them on this show because we need them
to sing cries oh by the way we're big
fans of them but they are big fans of us
they come every year I'm gonna see the
home-free fans are like the toasters
like they're so loud and passionate and
I just love having them on the show
right next up I can't like let anyone
come between us and home free right now
oh my god by the way and they're by the
way they love us they're like we have
this girl they want to be talking about
I made eye contact before and they like
music we see each other I'm coming to
your show but we definitely saw each
other you know yes okay I think they're
done let's get home free third year in a
row welcome to the morning toes we just
heard to see you guys we just heard your
Monticello rendition of old town road
you're so good it's so good to see you
we're so excited to talk to you and have
you sing for us obviously I feel like
everyone just like puts you to work on
this car but that's what we're here for
that's so true you guys are my favorite
ones on the whole record one more
alcohol this year there's a rule you're
not allowed to have so I guess I think
we definitely were the reason for that
rule you know I think we got a little
out of control like though you guys are
setting trends I love it next year
there's gonna be a no candy rule if you
ask me we just heard your rendition of
old town road and could be bad for you
to do it again because it was so
beautiful yeah
I can't
[Music]
don't lie did you practice out at home
before what are you guys toasting to
tonight it's the morning to us you ought
to make a toast
the women of country music popular
answer we love that we love seeing you
guys Congrats keep killing it and the
year we don't see you here to see a
minute words as a year I stopped coming
okay great same thing now with a packed
what cuties like Oh Jim Gaffigan scare
by the way I just saw him alone here
also AJ from the Backstreet Boys is
coming through yeah much to it for
children I'm just too bad so if you're
just tuning in hi welcome to the CMA how
are ya how are you I'm Claudia this is
my sister Jackie I keep talking over her
and I know and I'm really working on it
and I'm really sorry and I'm honestly
just happy to be here so like I don't
even realize something about home free
the band like gets my adrenaline is
rushing you're talking about before but
just at home free we're on a diet of
home free and no and it's it's working
okay so AJ from the Backstreet Boys is
coming up next he's like such a legend
it's like kind of weird to talk to
someone you know like so famous and make
such a part of your childhood like I
grew up with your face staring at me
while I slept right well more so like I
should tell him that I stared at your
face you know what I'm gonna not but I
I'm looking forward to speaking with him
who knew he was such a big fan of
country music yeah I mean who is it
honestly that's what you learn when
company these types of Awards it's like
Oh
Karlie Kloss was here where New York
gigi hadid is coming this year it's like
oh basically everyone is a fan of
country music like why am I not shocked
no it's just premium all three Miam all
the time
oh yeah premium content pretty much
being served up on the regular yeah much
like the morning toast the millennium
morning show we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we are
here with Xfinity and we couldn't be
happier we couldn't be happier I'm
having so much fun how much time has
gone by
it is it's 550 okay we have a little
over an hour left and there's still so
much this is the half way mommy got blue
cones we got Maren Morris but it's like
Kelsea Ballerini it's just like they say
in sports it's like the fourth quarter
is all that matters we're going into the
third quarter and things are just about
to like heat up here on the red carpet
so cheer because whenever I like I have
to watch sports with my husband I'm like
okay I'm only watching the last 20 20
minutes because because it's not about
how you start it's about how you finish
we're
finishing strong and hard but like we're
not even close to finishing so make sure
you grab a drink grab a snack I guess
it's like dinnertime for most people
grab a spoon and enjoy the show
I can hear home free singing oh my god
they work so hard by the way they're so
good like their voices are that was to
no good that was cream and it was also
like they had they took they had their
own spin on the song would you love
which is why I just needed to know if
they practice like if they just really
excuse me did that on the whim I'm was
just er up
I just like they did that on the whim
they would be so crazy but this is now
the third time they're doing it and I
feel bad for them yes because everyone's
just like keeps overhearing and it's
like telephone because it's very
impressive honestly it is um okay so we
are getting ready to talk to AJ from the
Backstreet Boys mclamb Miki and MacLean
he's it truly an icon it's kind of crazy
ya know and works he's gonna talk to
some fellow icons yeah well that's the
thing about icons so good to talk to
like another fellow I totally agree yeah
so I've seen that definitely on the
carpet already Luke Holmes in the
building I know Marin Morris and Ryan
herder in the building but it is a long
carpet out here you guys because you get
out that's where you guys are seeing
some of the arrivals and then there's a
photo area there's like a little chip
station and then there must be like 50
publications here so everyone's really
taking their time they want to talk to
everyone so it's gonna take a while for
everyone to get here because Luke Holmes
is in the building and he arrived like
20-30 minutes ago and I haven't seen or
heard from him in a minute and I know
he's supposed to be stopping by here
because I got an absolute promise from
his team no but I do see Walker Hayes
over there not related to Hunter Walker
he's a cutie yeah he's a real cutie he's
been on the show before and he's just a
really nice guy yeah very nice guy and
keeps growing like I heard about him
because he came on the show two years
ago and then I kept following him and he
really was growing and growing and then
I saw him last year and now I'm excited
to see him again I believe I see Scotty
McCreery as well oh we love Scotty
McCreery
Scotty McCreery we've got the Backstreet
Boy coming up I think we should open up
and let in let him in veteran and wonder
like if he has like a good time at these
things do you know anything else does
this work for him or he's just like
excited to be here welcome come on in
wow you look snazzy yes by our live
beautiful you look wonderful
good we are big fans of yours and we're
so excited to see you here at the CMAs
this is my first ever CMAs how's it
how's it going so far so far so good
who are you excited to see
well a little side note I just have a
little bit of a crush on dolly I've had
a crush on her since I was a kid doesn't
one hug from her that's all she seems
like yeah I hope so
I think you can get chewed and she's
about she boys him that one I don't know
I think actually when she said she was I
would I could die happy that would be
insane I have a question for you because
I feel like you had to go to a lot of
things like this and some people would
consider a tedious but you seem like a
fun guy like to have a lot of fun at
these things I do because this is kind
of where all of our peers can kind of
hang out and just kind of vibe and just
appreciate each other and have fun and
just enjoy good music and good people
yeah there's not to me as far as country
compared to pop there's not that much
competition here this is more about just
good people good music good pop is like
who has the most dreams who has the most
likes and all that it's just drama
everyone here seems really down-to-earth
and they just want to drink you know
straight true good drinking sing sure
we've got a lot of good collabs tonight
Willie Nelson and Kacey Musgraves a Lady
Antebellum in pink let's say you could
go thank you Matt Holliday let's say you
could collab with anyone here tonight
who would you want to sing with I would
say either Chris Stapleton or I think
Kerri and I would have a really good
like vocal battle thing going on she's
got that soul and I think I kind of do
as well I think you do another
humblebrag
thank you okay before we let you go this
is the morning show so we got to know
what are you trusting to tonight I am
toasting to being a proud father and
having the two most amazing girls a dad
could ever ask for
such a good answer would you like some
candy before you go maybe a mint like
Firenze while you're inside all right
maybe give them to some of your peers
nobody wants bad breath I don't I don't
suck on these like you're supposed to I
immediately chew it up Sunday that's how
it works the best I give you this entire
thing you probably feel like crap later
but yeah you're good so nice to meet you
thanks for stopping by have fun yeah
party have a drink
skyy totally toasting to his daughters
like I can't you trying to make me cry
yeah I think so like tear in my eye
okay I think we should take a quick
break yes I'm coming God there are some
arrivals coming in like booked
incredible I just like Kelsea Ballerini
she was the snatch Ellucian it's
official yeah she's wearing a two-piece
sequin office we're gonna cut to the red
carpet show you what's going to show you
um we'll be back in a few minutes stay
tuned have fun and go get the drink go
to the bathroom
you
Oh Walker hates grab Walker Hayes
okay everyone hope you enjoyed those red
carpet arrivals premium the stream
happening right now everyone really is
like putting their hair and makeup on
looking glam as hell and I think we're
gonna get the chance to talk with Matty
and tain a bit we love a little duo oh
my god we love a little magic
so cute and they said great here two
very interesting they released an album
release they're nominated for two of the
year right the album is flames check it
out they have a slab on there with
Derek's Bentley oh they had to go ahead
and they had to go so that's our
interview with Matt hey and honestly
should still be fans of them even though
they just it was a pleasure to talk to
them and I just hope they have a great
night and we're pulling for them you
ever poem for them but you know what
it's like they're not maybe for two of
the year like they can't just be like
slumming it with us no no even though
like we are nominated for duo of the
year yeah in a different time Tyler it's
good everything's good how are you guys
doing wow you look so beautiful you know
that's really sweet thank you guys are
very it's just the perfect amount thank
you very much you know bring back that
old uh did you think you were gonna be
the only one wearing them and then
everyone's wearing them absolutely not
but I'm the only one wearing or wolf
runs so far that I've seen which is very
Game of Thrones are you a stark yeah
yeah absolutely 100% I think you're
definitely more of like a Targaryen
Lannister I do but you give me a Cersei
vibe but you were so north
you're so Northman there's men for a
particular wall but I'm a Targaryen you
know I'm like Jon Snow's half brother
and we're both half and a half can you
have sex with your aunt oh my it's
pretty hot there she is
and now my wife is so keen you look
wonderful tonight how long have you been
married seven weeks yeah Wow newlywed
how does it feel so nice
it's sweet like yesterday it doesn't
change but it changes it does it does
I'm okay for CMA Awards
yes look in this carpet incredible why
we've watched this show a million times
from home from across the street at bars
from everywhere before he's gone to the
after parties but we've never been able
to do the carpet actually attend the
show so we're excited how difficult is
it for you to stare at this candy he's
got the worst sweet tooth of all time
I've been staring my mouth water what
can we offer you great out of the shade
out of the water
okay so it's the morning toast before we
let you go let us know what are you
gonna toast you tonight oh man we're
toasting to man oh yeah we'll toast you
that that's good I was at yeah new
singles called rather be us love it will
toast that but we'll just toast to being
lucky enough to come and be a part of
this event and with all of our peers
amen that's how we feel too so nice to
meet you guys have fun enjoy your first
CMAs have a drink party go kill it
thank you for having nice to meet you
guys we have we've got more stocked up
so so nice to meet you have so much fun
we smell good too I love her look it's
party in the front of my business if she
is meant to be famous she's a star I
know and also she's like one of my
frontrunners for Best Dressed so far
from what I've seen her the other parts
just snatchler but not many to the
carpet well like famous people have come
down here that's right that's the also
haven't seen men considering this is a
big night for women also it's just like
I feel like everyone's been media
trained to be like women in country do
you know I mean it's like everyone's
give me that answer and it doesn't feel
genuine so I mean when they say it it
actually you're right it just seems like
I feel nearly as genuine a DJ and his
daughters which was literally brought a
tear to my eye I totally agree it's like
we took so much time in our makeup you
can't just be toasting to your daughters
okay by the way so now a little bit of a
down time
what are you tossing to tonight oh my
god I'm living a country
I'm toasting to women on the red carpet
who do a show called the morning toast
no I'm toasting for the opportunity to
be here because we just love the country
music we love the cma awards and then
did you CMAs for life constantly putting
up a grateful to be here I'm grateful to
Xfinity for sponsoring our stream and
just to have this wonderful opportunity
to do what we love amongst people that
were such big fans of yeah and speaking
of us speaking of people that were such
big fans of we have Walker hey I'll take
some candy go for it maybe a middle for
the road yeah these are very popular
cookie jaw you're on your own your phone
we're just watching ourselves how are
you I'm so good you have had a great
year yeah yeah I mean dude I'm here so
obviously my year hasn't been that bad I
think this is our third year in the row
two in a row talking to you is it yeah
that's good hopefully we'll have four or
five and say yeah we vote we all have
jobs yeah I have and it's nice to be
home good lord it is nice to be home and
holidays coming up so like a little bit
of light at the end of that travel of
tunnel what are some holiday traditions
you never never let oh shoot you know
Laney and I my wife won one of our
favorite things to do we go this
restaurant called bricks and they have
paper on the tables that you can draw on
so we get six feet of that every year
and we tape it on the wall of our house
and the kids draw a tree so demo stick a
treatment so we have them like rolled up
and we have them from several years back
so yeah it's cool and we don't have to
have like the mess of a tree sometimes
the dog like what's you the corner of
the paper but that's worst-case scenario
dog-ate-my-homework yeah yeah that's a
nice tradition I'm just gonna say like
eggnog you know is gross that's terrible
no one ever said no one ever give me a
glass of eggnog unless they were drunk
already and they were like yeah that's
hot yeah
yeah people ask you or assume that
you're related to Hunter Hayes I mean
just because our names are the same yes
and I like it you know I always want to
see him and be like hey does everybody
call you Walker cuz I get called hunter
all the time so don't not look alike
right now right I guess I don't know
clear the air are you related or not we
are not related but I would take him you
know if we did the 23andme and it
happens to be that he's mine
you know son yes or that would be weird
I mean either that would mean I had a
kid but you were really young you know
maybe he's my cousin maybe baby I'm his
uncle
maybe baby's not enough for you Connor
well congrats on being careful and we
are so happy to talk to you thank y'all
if you want to take some candy for the
road Oman is free am i invite lani over
here please she want some candy lady I
was a cutie reminds me if she's all that
I love the lady nice thank you so much
have a great night you want some candy
candy
are you sure these are gonna mint for
the road like we try to accommodate we
have to be try this year we can't have
any alcohol so so you just have got it
bottle the profits a profit empty yep or
it's actually open doping around that
open it this is also thank you make sure
you anything else
that's true but you know it looks good
though it happens
well pink has arrived you guys that's
the building she do you think this is
the closest we'll ever physically be to
pink I don't know like we have you know
hopefully there's more award shows like
you just never know it's too many people
go to a concert of hers and like be in
the front row I would love to see pink
in concert oh my god me too I've
actually heard she's amazing and spends
like more than half of the concert
upside down in a trapeze because she's
so stick kidding me Ranga red lipstick
yes wait you look so great would you
like some candy
this is Kaylee Dickerson wait I have so
much you need to talk to you about oh my
god wait this is Cassie Kelly you need
okay okay I need to name you just avoid
hear about the house oh my gosh it's
almost we're gonna move in yourself time
stories drive me nuts because I just
need to see a complete I mean say okay
so you have a new house but you're never
home so like what's the point that's a
very valid question and I don't know
until ago delicious to be honest you
know I'm not yet working on any great
for reading morning to you were on tour
forever VHS yes I know is rusty yet
going out on tour again yes he is a girl
unless you do good nerves what nerve I
know
going on tour again Kayne Brown and the
in the spring no that's legit a cell
yeah you like going on tour yeah
actually look US tour girls yeah we do
her all the time you turn your jammies
and I tour in like I mean leggings it's
kind of this I love lugging yes and you
just really you have become like such
like a staple like I just love you like
yeah I'm obsessively I really you're not
missing them this is by the way he's way
back there I ditched him because us
girls are going to get a drink you guys
are so key not fan of your husband he's
a member of Lady Antebellum and we're so
excited to talk to them Oh
partner yeah that's know I call her the
first lady of country music look at her
like get the chance to talk to him like
something terrible happens like they've
been doing this thing recently where
there's just like casually dropping
bangers like some of the best songs I'm
not Catholic and it's like what is it I
mean you must be the inspiration behind
yes she is the songs are so good and
like what did we do to deserve this
they are so talented and just I mean the
three of them are constantly just
putting out new stuff and they're super
excited about this new record it comes
out Friday look at that ocean and hi
people I have to tell you something also
the only reason we're here is because of
Lady Antebellum they got us into country
music like there was the first country
concert we ever went to when we thought
we were like no the first time I saw him
in New York he was I could really smell
that you made it it was like a not
Webster Hall but like something like
that maybe something that's not even
like in New York anymore but then we saw
them but then we saw them at Radio City
Music Hall that was when I was in
college and they like the inter tour
they you guys have been along for the
ride the whole time for a while I was
like who was Lea tell him like who is
she
like a person Gaga came up with their
Lady names like around the same time as
Lady got right sprays confusing but
excited the country lady well I know you
guys wanted to go get the drinks we want
to hold you if you want some candy
please feel free to take I'm gonna have
a gummy bear yes Russell that he doesn't
find us like I'm not his friend anymore
and I'm not gonna FaceTime him when I'm
drunk a new Burres anymore - always
being played on the radio he does clawed
his face having me with it and you're in
his bone you are clawed with no job I
only face I didn't want to hear his song
and I walked into Dwayne Reed the other
daenam song I was on I was like I can't
call Russell again you can't get it like
take this holiday I guess for you it's
not that crazy like for me I'm like I
know someone on the radio you know it's
still surreal it's crazy that I feel
free I still feel that when it comes on
yeah what are you guys gonna drink um I
don't know all right go
oh nice is it room for two in your dress
that's a no okay we got it we don't know
but you'd be welcome you look so
beautiful
wow she really looks great that was so
fast Lee who's my fishy Josh Lee oh wait
we didn't tell her about Kevin oh it's
Kelly right whether we got Rodney Atkins
snacks anyway by the way if you didn't
like you just like no no no I know she's
away for glady a her last name is Kelly
I'm the one Ethan would you get or is it
dry - Kelly which might be the husband
of the other guy yeah Dave Dave Kelly
that doesn't have Kelly it's Josh Kelley
is that the tall hot singer I know the
driver trauma driver Ellie Josh bucket
Josh Kelly's married to Kathy no I know
Kelly wife let's just say I'm pretty
sure you're right
oh god it's not coming up Claudia knows
you guys soap and I love the wives of
punch oh my god they're even better than
you live okay we have Rodney Atkins
coming and I'm so excited and his wife
Rose which was just a beautiful name
that was her and they have a bed back
which is just so exciting is the bebut
here okay this is under lease give em a
yeah okay thank God our good did you
just need to confirm that his name is
Charles Kelley
widget because he's a brother Josh who
is it stop talking I'll do my absolute
best but no promises okay who do we
learnt that was exciting
we have Rodney Atkins next and let me
just like Nico Nicole
excuse me I mean we were notes where are
are no Nino's hello
Lu combs come through oh my god
beautiful precious doing wonderfully
wonderfully you look so beautiful oh my
god thank you here you go you guys we
are so shocked by your present to talk
to you like both of you okay
we have been listening to your new album
non-stop since it came out on I can't
believe it's only been seven days that
we've had your album I already know the
whole thing I like it - I like it too I
like that that's good to hear yes
absolutely
relieved relieved yes absolutely we want
to talk to you about because you're
playing your first stadium tour in May
yes and it's not your college alma mater
I will be there Laura I'll be texting
you separately Nicole about some tickets
is that crazy like that's what you
started on vine like now you're just
coming back to what it's at like 60,000
people I think it's like 35 we're just
still a lot so yeah but no it's it's
gonna be it's gonna be really fun I'm
looking forward to it what's also gonna
be really find us tonight because you're
nominated for male vocalist of the year
if it were up to us like the trophy
would be yours well thank you appreciate
the answer male vocalist and it's been
your year thank you appreciate so I want
to talk to you about your new album
because obviously in the spring you came
out with beer never broke my heart and
it's the most epic song of all time
because it's not just a head banger it's
a neck snap er next snapper yeah I like
that I was gonna say how do you not
injure your neck I do have a couple of
crik crik totally and you've seen the
Waffle House video oh yes show me that
how does that make you feel like that
just like it's a song that brings people
together that's awesome I have been
incapacitated in a Waffle House singing
many times so it was an honor to be the
person being sung and not the person
singing but I have had a largemouth bass
bust my line yes of course and that's
just so crazy that you have to
absolutely we all have we've all been
there we've all been there absolutely
like we're both just in you know New
York gals you know how do you write a
line like that I've had a largemouth
bass
bust my line the good things about it's
just like it's it's kind of like redneck
imagery that's kind of everyone cuz like
I wouldn't consider our rednecks but
like I feel your lyrics like to the core
it can be like it's it's more of a
metaphor it's not it's not the bass
itself
what find your bass if you're out there
right okay it could be your heel
breaking off in a super-great that could
be your version you know I mean if like
that's a new york-based
potentially I'm not at liberty to say on
camera hey you guys look great can we
talk about the suit this dress like
where's the from who's who is it you
remember when you go to these things all
the time so true you're just used to it
also we have your new Instagram name
because you guys are engaged you even
have to change your Instagram name are
you gonna become Nicole Combs right no
so you need to be me combs that's what I
thought that's already had to know you
guys should have a contact or combs the
bride yes I love that that's like he's
the artist and wear the sari people I
know it's probably an annoying question
but when are you guys gonna get married
I'm sure everyone's asking that you have
a date we do oh okay wait that's all we
won't be into two inches a little but
I'm happy for you thank you does that
mean you're gonna have to stop playing
shows for one day to go on tour maybe
one day what we're gonna probably gonna
do more like a whole month of office
which will be very nice yep yes hang out
you know do whatever
where are the honeymoon destinations we
actually we don't know we don't know
that's that's what we actually really
don't know yes I got married two years
ago I'm taking my honeymoon in February
sometimes we're going for our
anniversary it's just like couldn't do
it can't plan a wedding and a honeymoon
it's just too freakin hard luck it's a
lot visual I know this is like the night
of your life and I promise we'll let you
go but I should have a few more things
to say we tell you at stagecoach and I
can't even put into words like the way
you made me feel like I've seen you in
concert before we show you my tattoo
square guard and we literally follow you
around I don't know if you know but I do
I do
we got all your shows we like
father Kathy on Instagram like all the
time but I can't describe the way you
made me feel at stagecoach like with the
Sun and you had such a great time so you
know I was a little upset because I
thought you should have been a headliner
then it's like it's a little too dark
it's a little too dark like the Sun is
setting when you were playing it was
quite beautiful pretty cool so I think
you really actually got the better
timeslot but I was just thinking I was
like I just know I'm gonna be like 97
years old banging my head to be our
never broke my word and I just you know
like I want to thank you for for making
me feel that way you know a lot of
people feel that way and I just love you
well thank you very much our husbands
who like really did want to be at
stagecoach love you too
you made them country music fans so we
can't we've been like thinking about
this moment forever and I just really
want to let you go but like I know
you're busy because you're gonna win all
the awards say like to even get nervous
because like you just know it's like no
drama needed for so many that like the
odds are in your favor right yes you
know I'm in it who knows gonna cut to
you on camera if he wins so what's your
surprise base I mean I just kind of let
happen sometimes it's like give you a
few pointers and you just have to be
like you know yeah you know relax like a
little less a little less beautiful
beautiful and now don't lie do you have
a speech written I don't that's such a
lie are you sure I'm sure
oh yeah cuz you're a humble man I am you
know I just want I just want to say what
I want to say you know I'm I don't want
to plan it because then I feel like only
thing you can do when you plan the
speech out to me is mess it up I agree
and then if I don't have a speech plan
then I can't mess it up yeah you know I
just go up there and say whatever I'm
feeling in that moment me that's that's
the best way to go you also collab with
Eric Church and like Church just like
doesn't collab likey with anyone you
know yes it's a big deal yes I'm very
excited a big big fan you know I'm
rooting for him tonight
opening come home with some hardware
tonight so but yeah that was really
awesome full circle moment for me for
sure okay we are going to let you go but
my sister Margo will absolutely set my
throat if you don't have say hello Margo
hello snitch hello Margo hello snitch
get Luke and Nicole here wish you were
here she's your number one fan well
we're big fans she's an even bigger than
it
we told her to come we got her a press
credential but she said I literally
can't like I will die like she'll die
like she can she's too much it's too
much too starstruck
she wears your Crocs like everywhere we
all do honestly best collab ever love
you I don't know if you came up with it
before wheel driving the two wheel drive
that's hilarious
like it was meant to work with Crocs I'm
Corner actually say I am also a Crocs -
hashtag Crocs partner on Instagram so
we're just like in the Crocs family
absolutely got custom Crocs with custom
gibbets I love it I love you we need it
we need a nicole fashioned Crocs line
you need a bridal shower wedge a wedge
a Christmas a [ __ ] looks like a little
veil coming out of the heel for your
wedding after the ceremony
Crocs get on it I love it okay have fun
if I don't see you on after party I'm
coming to your house and knocking down
the door love you so much both of you
all right thank you thank you everyone
now you're selling out 35,000 stadiums
like we were your fans first like like I
knew your song like waiting for all
these little [ __ ] freeloaders did and
work works your fans and slow dance but
like where we are legit oh geez oh we
saw you like three years ago that's all
you do three years ago on the red carpet
right when the video came out for when
the rains it pours and I was like you
guys this guy is it and I was right
you're right liquor we're not allowed
anymore because we're in music city
center
they said we couldn't have alcohol which
is why we had to supplement with candy
we felt really badly but like we don't
know I'm okay I'm okay well the last
time I took that warm shot of tequila on
it was like this boring as hell yeah
awesome thank you ladies love you tell
Cappy we say hi
Wow Wow you guys I'm broken here we
heard about no time to be briefed on
that Ryan the man of the hour he looks
so hot yes hello how are you welcome to
the toast I love your come to the toast
yeah that's right how many of these guys
have been in studio are you guys not not
that many no you're actually like you're
our only real welcome but yes those a
blast can I offer you some candy before
we get started that's sweet tart yes
bring it let's do it very specific
choice well I mean everything else is
pretty you know I just don't see a lot
of sweet tarts anymore I can't believe
we're standing next to a future father
he can't believe it either this is a big
deal it's fun to be able to talk about
it
we had we kept it to ourselves for quite
a while and and now that it's like for
everybody everybody's news it's it's fun
to just get to talk about it I mean
Marion's really excited she feels
everybody asked how she feels I think
she feels pretty good I think she likes
being pregnant but yeah everything has
just been like so new learning a lot and
well yeah it's definitely the coolest
part of our year how far along is she
uh I think we're doing the spring so I
guess we're backwards from there I can't
believe that you guys are having a boy
like after all this you know she's such
a feminist icon I think she was really
excited about having them boy I thought
she might like kind of like lean toward
having a girl and she had a preference
but I think I almost saw like relief in
her face when she found out because uh I
think she grew up in a salon and she has
a sister so she's always been around
women and I think like the idea of
having a boy was new for her and
something really exciting I don't know
what she's seen I'm excited to add it
neither one of us had a preference
obviously everybody says that but like I
think the one like we started getting
used to that idea we both I think are
really excited
think the next album will be called boy
[Laughter]
was called boy if people would think
that was pretty weird well you've had
quite a year when we saw you what six
months ago and you've done so much yeah
first gold record wow that's huge yeah -
at ease a gold single now which is
amazing that was my only goal when I
signed my record contract I'm really
pumped because tonight I wrote a song
that Lady Antebellum is performing we
love it and Halsey is singing sickening
violet I've been listening to both of
the songs thinking like how the hell do
you put those together so I'm I'm
excited to see how they do it cuz they
they seem like hard that seems hard to
do yeah but by the way that song is
still good when you write a song like
that how do you decide whether to keep
it for yourself or to give it away
that's a good question it's really hard
to get cuts in Nashville and other
people's records so anytime that
somebody records your song it's like
such an honor they could record that
like sing it the rest of their career
that being said like that one maybe I
appreciate the honesty Ryan heard I
really do yeah I'm okay before we let
you go this is the morning toast what
are you gonna toast you tonight Marin
winning all the trophies yeah man she we
love you thank you for coming on yes
what are your time have fun tonight when
you have to open it in here we'll get
we'll get kicked out they cook us out
they say as I read carpet this year how
lame is that the realty the realty left
super early we couldn't see that my name
I saw them leave I was really upset no
let me eat some candid you saw that the
hardest gummy bear ever
that's like devastated like too many
premium back-to-back gasps Oh chase rice
was just behind me and I got to talk to
him oh oh great Kelsey's coming very
exciting but I still haven't debriefed
Nokomis hell she looks amazing I'm just
gonna make our contribution let's go
back to art this is my side that's here
I look pregnant from the side though so
okay we have eyes on the prize
she looks [ __ ] sick she really does
everyone now crew is just in latest feel
like I never really I don't know but I
don't like him yes please good to know
okay if you chase rice oh my god I have
so much to talk to you about rice
welcome to the toast yeah but we can't
have alcohol music city center that's
ridiculous
I agree I got a I gotta ask you a couple
questions now this is a spoiler alert if
you watch The Bachelor but it is true
that you are performing on an upcoming
episode of Peters season mm-hmm it's
also true you're entangled in a little
bit of a love triangle when it comes to
one of the contestants is that true
there's no love triangle I'll tell you
that
shucks shucks the loves on their side no
I I wish them the best I don't know what
happens there but I wanted to go on and
promote my music lonely pure I saw I had
a heart worm took the time I'll sing
while you while you chew if you would
like Jose no I want to go on and promote
lonely if you are oz on you when they
brought a little extracurricular
activity into that they're very sneaky
that way they are you don't know with
this outfit are you kidding look
incredible by the way it's all it's your
night
it's all happening for you I'm so
excited for you can I see you later okay
bye love you okay back to the sneakiness
of the ABC production and honestly I
I really need to hear more obviously
they set you up yeah I mean they said
everybody up but here's my thing I
didn't sign up for that no that's so
true that's my problem with it I'm at
the end of the day they have a job to do
and I don't need to be part of that I
mean I went on there to promote my music
and that's all that should have been
it wasn't so conveniently though
whatever week that airs I will be
putting out in music that way oh great
you know everyone stream chase nice if
you're after you watch the eyes on you
is such a good song like you're really
killing it I feel like we've spoken to
you at the CMA it's like three three
years in a row and every year just
getting bigger and bigger and I
literally said to you two years ago then
I think you should date a contestant
from the baxter like i think that would
be great for ya and i was like kind of
right I also said Lauren Bushnell she
dates a country singer and she ended up
marrying one so I think I'm just like
making a marriages Lauren Lane is her
name now I keep talking about this
Hannah girl this year
oh are you interested in her she's
single she's down at the front if you
were a big white wedding you know it's
it's not very subtle music anything
bachelor related I'll stay away from
[ __ ] it yeah you're better without it
well everyone stream eyes on you please
take a piece of candy for the road and
it is so great to see you again tonight
you're fun time you know you did have a
good time for sure good good good
honestly I'm in Hanabi I should meet you
at Shea [ __ ] cheese Reese was being
so chatty and I'm like oh my god we miss
Kelsey I know but then we got Kelsey and
also like chase gave us some tea about
getting set up on ABC by the way that
was [ __ ] drama licious delicious yeah
we've been like ditching him because
like better people are coming I thought
we were working hard on this carpet but
Scotty McCreery has been out here since
we had weather i Scotty McRae's been out
here since 2005 when he won American
Idol and Lauren Elena who lost him is
more famous yes I mean he should go
dancing with the stars okay by the way
that's always how it happens by there
that was like in a crazy thirty minutes
like that was a crazy thirty minutes
Wow Kelsey looks so freaking she little
show good I would love to know relating
into the elements because I got two
charts that I got a bunch questions for
them yeah never
that was funny how Ryan heard it was
like I wish I kept that song like it
that it I guess it's hard when like he
writes so many songs and you don't know
what's gonna hit with him and that Lady
Antebellum song like did so well and I
guess he's probably like I wish I [ __ ]
kept it for myself
honestly they should send the song
to us and like we'll let them know if
they're gonna be here we're a great
barometer that's over there what's it
called ANR like I think if this doesn't
work out I'm gonna go into A&R
but I think this is working out I think
so look what these dandies were country
music's biggest fans on country music's
biggest night we are partnered with
Xfinity I mean could not be happier to
be here we on the morning toast and we
are grateful my chocolate how upset I am
that that confirm American Idol last
year it hasn't shown up yeah like his
name was Caleb Johnson I want to say
Caleb something and I just have a lot I
need to talk to him about I know maybe
we could like get him on the toast if
he's not here tonight you know like do
an interview I just I don't
I'll take him via satellite to the
bottom of his dry cleaning mill from -
Sierra I'm gonna bet this bin to my
mother I feel like I'm talking so
closely to people with like the worst
breath I know I now had like gummy bear
breath I really can't believe how many
like party tarts he's so tall yeah yeah
I feel like I'm into us yeah yeah well
okay how's it run feeling okay feelin
struggling berries here okay seasons
change you guys because I need you
you're like great this is your guys
match we talked last night and we text
all the time how are you I'm good
okay this is what like you're eight CMA
Awards number nine Wow Wow I just
guessed oh yeah that's a good guess
you've come really far from the American
Idol days yes some days it feels like
yesterday and the other it's like man
was that like fifty years ago all the
time and she's actually a great friend
of mine but are you sure there's no
competition between you and Lauren Elena
anymore
oh we secretly hate each other I think
so she is crushing on dancing sir by the
way we went to go see her we watched
live from the audience she was
incredible yeah I couldn't do it I
couldn't do it
okay so ninth CMA Award you ever get
like sick of it or it's always just like
a spectacle no so much fun so much fun
you get gummy bears right yes
can I offer you something maybe a mint
for the road you don't wanna have bad
breath backstage oh is that a message
that we've been giving up to everyone
we've been giving them to ever on it and
by the way I'm secretly stuck in one
right here because I really don't wanna
have bad
can we offer you some pepto-bismol yeah
and any indigestion
Stephen diarrhea yeah that's a great
song campaign I figured I like did my
prep I was like I'm gonna answer this
question we talked about this I was I
didn't know I'd be talking my
pepto-bismol tonight you can expect here
on the morning toast
anything can happen before we let you go
this is the morning toast we have to ask
you what are you looking forward to
buddy gonna chose tonight toast tonight
well I'm hoping to toast my boys all
dominions we have a show at work we have
bus call them out of 11 we're going to
Tulsa Oklahoma with them for the weekend
Wow and if they win tonight it's gonna
be a big party all weekend long so I'm
pretty toasting honestly I'm rooting for
them now just so you have a great
weekend
yeah thank you very much Jim we love you
good time tonight see you party on we'll
do our best
we make no promises Scotty I saw Mitch
on the murder from afar where we got to
get him snitch Elana penny
Mitchell - Oh Lorna Chris Mitch on the
toast marinate drunk oh my god Lauren
acts like Belle at the end of Beauty and
the Beast I'm sure ashes
angel oh my god okay we see each other
we see each other they look so your
dress but it's like yellow also I didn't
mean to talk about my kind of brown is
wearing a full [ __ ] wedding dress oh
you guys it's happening when it rains it
pours
you look it's the lanes um you look
insane in the best way welcome Mazel Tov
guys look so great are you intentionally
dressed like Beauty and the Beast
tonight yeah you look like the Beast and
you look like a beauty like not no
offense but Nicki and she would need to
be but you look at her blue suit and she
wore a yellow dress okay Lauren I don't
meet you amber shoe but I was to
speaking with Chris earlier today and we
are going to ambush you because we want
you to sing for us I know it's a CMA
Awards what am I saying
at night for us it's almost the holiday
season yeah it is yeah it's almost
holiday season and we gotta get us our
man and we're Jewish we're Jewish it's
on our phones okay you guys you're
married what like a day now come on zip
in how's it going you guys did that real
quick I enjoyed that um miss miss Dayton
yes Amanda Stanton did accidentally
spoil on our show that she got your
wedding invitation to a new it was like
for to see for me how yeah depending on
language in here and they really bad you
know I'm we actually did cut it out of
our podcast put the live show live
television people are gonna do what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do how
was it like how do you feel you feel
different yes no no like we lived
together and like it doesn't really
change a relationship but yeah it feels
great to be like oh this is my husband
Chris yes is it so crazy out last year
this awards you were just announcing
that you were dating and like now you're
here married is it totally different I
mean I feel more comfortable because at
the time we had just I mean literally
what kind of forced us to define the
relationship was the CMAs again our
publicist was like so you guys gotta
define the relationship and you know
what it was pretty much defined for you
yes exactly so this is a little more
comfortable I'm a little more used to
this whole thing now yeah
oh my god you guys just looks so great
you're killing it you guys are never
home but you're moving into a beautiful
new house you guys have to come stay
with us we would love to next year the
carpet together
like silent night rendition might kick
off I think we're already nominated
she'll be new artist of the year next
year just wait it's very true yeah
okay you're on the road you just and you
just started a new tour right yeah I
just started a headlining tour which is
exciting I'm glad I get to have my honey
bun out there on the road do you like
going on the road yes yes I do it's
really fun
yes no going to say he was on one bus
and it was me and 12 guys oh yeah she
had to be on the bus with 11 or so
enjoyed it but now he's on two busses
I'm a little more room I can like change
and not worry about like one of you know
his drummer coming in or whatever which
is also his brother so that would even
be more off oh my god by the way so I
can't believe that I have known you now
well like not really knowing you but
like known like I knew you'd be getting
at me I'm for like three years
and I just had I do have a [ __ ]
twin he looks I mean I know the touch
wounds work but he looks just like you
identical twin right he's not as cool
though that's oh yeah okay every push
I'm not to be weird but like they're so
like similar looking do you ever feel
like attracted to the twin it's a valid
question okay yeah have you thought
about that
no now I am now because of you I am oh
man you guys are so cute
are you excited you like going to these
things you find I'd like to be a lot of
pressure you have a good time like we'll
go in and we'll enjoy it tonight and
then I'll jump right back out on the
road later tonight oh you're leaving
tonight yeah yeah we are you know I'm
saying back do you want to hang out okay
we'll keep her company all right do it
thank you I appreciate that tomorrow all
right do you guys have so much fun at
this oh my god the best night of the
year
we're just such big fans of everyone who
walks the carpet that we just get to
fangirl and work and like yeah I think
I'll be have more fun here than we what
if we were ever invited to the Grammys
to do this like Pharrell yeah all right
well you guys actually get to go inside
so have a good time they said candy yeah
bag some candy and we're gonna grab some
raelynne honestly I would tell my god
you might have bad breath looking
right everyone can hear me but they
can't so much talking look I've been
sucking on this little candy with the so
beautiful we have can maybe have the
lanes club we have Raylan monger every
rail in Monroe is here
Mary Marilyn's cousin Marilyn's cousin
your titties look amazing I'm not gonna
lie you look so incredible at the BMI
last night and I didn't know like how or
if you would top it but this is an
incredible look really thank you Sam
this might be your best I think I love
Tadashi Shoji is amazing and like I was
gonna wear this other dress that was
completely polar opposite like more
color and all of a sudden then I tried
this on I was like holy shitake
mushrooms that's it yeah and the gloves
are part of the dress yes oh wow you
look amazing thank you all so I just
need to tell you because it was just
Veterans Day and you are the wife
someone in the Army we carry mad
military man furniture man so high died
watching you like you're so funny you've
so much energy you're such a great
performing even new song bra off it's so
good oh my god you are very much emulate
you're promoting your album right now
your new song broth I should be hashtag
tape okay trust me about the new song
how did it come out so I basically wrote
it about this douchebag that I was
dating and how it felt to break up with
him and I think it doesn't matter like
douchebags are still hot and you think
you know it's gonna be suck to break up
with this dude and then I broke up with
him and I was like oh my god this looks
great yeah Oh son my friend of mine I
was like God breaking up with someone so
I was like taking my bra off and she's
like holy [ __ ] that's gonna be a song
and honestly I extreme type of girl 45
minutes I like my bra on though so my
song would be called bra on so like the
feeling of just feeling like supported
and like my neck doesn't hurt you know
because your support says something I
you
is that ones that make you keep a bra
that's eternal and you're happy it
really is such like a multifaceted like
metaphor do you'd want to take it off if
like you weren't happy you know hurting
you getting into your side of the wire
I'm tell you it's a deep [ __ ]
metaphor okay you printed somebody CMA
Awards you ever get like it you ever get
over it or it's still like it's still
glamorous it's so fun I think it's so
much fun to just dress up and honestly
like I used to watch a CMAs every year
as a kid and the fact that I get to be a
part of it I think when you start to
take that for granted but you shouldn't
be in this business I you know and you
certainly shanty in country no no and I
just I think if you can honestly cheer
on your fellow friends that have had
success then when you have that success
they're gonna cheer you on that's so
true that's a great attitude I love you
oh my god I love seeing him you look so
great you're healing the looks this
weekend
I can't wait to see me look like later
you changing you're doing an after party
dress are wearing I'm wearing a bra
please take my skin scuse me I love you
Raylan I hope you have a good time wow
you look stunning like seriously and I'm
sorry oh my god okay I was trying to
think in my mind who we haven't seen yet
oh no he's right there okay it's natural
tan pan and also Lady Antebellum has not
shown up yet but like is it overeating
oh it's it's six to seven we have
breasts eating is Lady Antebellum
anywhere to be found
okay that's too bad okay she's in the
building building okay that's exciting
well well I'm gonna tackle Mitchell
Tenpenny
maybe we will see you lady maybe there's
just coming later because like they're
just like so prestigious yeah but you
guys wanted say hi to everyone if you're
watching us on YouTube and you're a fan
of the morning toast it's so nice to see
you we hope you're enjoying the stream
if you are watching on Xfinity x1
welcome we hope you don't think we're
annoying Xfinity brings you closer to
the things you love including Lady
Antebellum
catch an exclusive encore performance of
let it be love right after the show
tonight just say go like this if you
want to watch it it's actually said this
remote is so crazy so we have this
remote and if you want to watching the
Lady Antebellum encore performance you
take the remote mm-hmm press the mic
button
lady antebellum only on Xfinity just
like that press the button lady Xfinity
off the performance will start it's an
encore performance sponsored by Xfinity
partner with Xfinity we've loved being
on Xfinity x1 thank you guys so much for
having me rarely haven't we love Lady
Antebellum slingbacks we're body after
the shacks where I will be watching we
didn't necessarily get invited into the
CMAs I mean even if I did I would be
watching the encore performance on
Xfinity with Lady Antebellum hundred
percent when I met Rachel
where's oh they're here she'll talk to
the lanes which we already did it's so
cute by the way his girlfriend is a
[ __ ] snatch Mitchell Mitchell
Mitchell
Tara how you doing I'm living for your
suit oh thank you so much are your hat
like you're so formal but like usual I'm
just chill I don't care this is I don't
know why I'm here it's a dry party about
to have this is ridiculous no I know we
usually have a full card I think you
were here with us last year we usually
have a full cart with shots and
everyone's so popular nothing's dry
about Nashville yeah Jim Gaffigan yes
sorry you know it's a live show you
gotta keep it keep it
your girlfriend is snatched and be
default like if she's setting I am very
lucky and that's why she's here cuz I'm
ugly and we need to take the attention
off her off of me and put it all on her
you got a great year like so many
Baker's released like really your song
the one that I live for is drunk drunk
me you can't get over you cannot get
over the song right me too I'm always
drunk and drunk we can really never get
over that song a lot too we're also
gonna be performing at stagecoach this
coming era here just like stagecoach
sands are you so excited yes our first
time to do the main stage too so we're
so excited about that last year was so
hot and crazy and just getting about it
bad that was like such an atmosphere out
there was awesome and that's where we
kind of met yeah yeah and if I was just
like a country singer which I think that
I am I would definitely want to perform
at CHS yeah it's like the place to be
it's the pinnacle of like cool it's just
everything yeah well hey I'm coming back
come on this is morning chosen I've been
on our show before before we let you go
you have a busy night what are you gonna
toast to I'm gonna tell us to getting to
come with my girlfriend that's an
amazing thing she is and I'm blessed
that you know be able to do this with
her so it's fun would you like some
candy
I would love some cake
yeah girlfriend here girlfriend yeah
love y'all either guys you're the best
yes so rude yeah like trying to keep us
down oh my god well I'm like out of
breath Oh Nicole Kidman and Keith Urban
are in the building cheating begin as
possibly coming I just letting them in
airplane he was so nice Oh rusty dick is
over there I have a lot to talk to him
about Jesse James Decker did not want to
talk to us I think that's an interesting
thing to note i think it's cuz we like
touch your belly and like that's not a
cool to her last year when she was
pregnant and I like touch her pregnant
belly without actually asking permission
and I do think I mean and I think you
have to ask yeah so it's not my fault
for not knowing things no and like
that's what we get but um Jimmy a vegan
would be insane
you said Nicole Kidman and Keith Urban I
just want to see her in person I don't
ever expect her to come on they should
just want to say like Jim Gaffigan is
talking to a nobody so why wouldn't he
talk to us why not talk to these
nobodies we have candy we're nobodies
but like some people know who we are so
I think it's well yeah it's better till
crazy how like it literally is so quiet
for an hour and then everyone shows up
at the same time now see quite again
very spooky but I feel like some people
are gonna come at the end like and just
want to tear through our camera it's
coming I'm not gonna stop I'm not gonna
stop until we get around them I know he
just went back to the girl making shorts
there's a girl who's like very
nourishing all of our content and and
I'm just I'm not gonna rest are you a
Jim berry mom here she knows
one question we only get one question
think of it a [ __ ] okay I'm how do you
how do you in the Netflix special help
me know okay don't make it okay not make
one question we're thinking of the best
question cuz Jim's in Russia see make up
maybe sending our country music like um
by the way this is so hard like this is
on you who oh yeah we'll grab coconut we
are now Jim Gaffigan first well we're
not losing Jim Gaffigan for a bird in
the hand is worth two in the bush no but
by the way I know his publicist okay we
are going together maybe like holding
hands you can wait I feel like they have
a minute but the way no offense Colton
Cassie have a lot of time like a
negotiate so do I like they're not as
important that you have one question
they can honestly what bring students
see me is that no I
like and I think that'll spiral like a
little bit late publicist a1 but they
mean like three you know and if he's
having a good time like he can leave
whenever came on we only really a time
for one question because that girl cut
us off okay and I also think I'm gonna
give him my microphone and I'm gonna let
you take the reins and I'm just gonna
like so yeah this like I'm really his
number one fan I always say it like he's
my favorite comedian and I met on a
plane and he wasn't rude so like that I
would you ask him question will you come
to one of my shows the [ __ ] you doing
here yeah actually presents a lot he
presented at the Grammys because he gets
nominated a lot because there's a
category for comedy album and Chris Rock
or Noah T Chapelle wins every year but
Jim Gaffigan has actually presented at
the Grammys once or twice which is
actually really prestigious and cool and
he's also wearing a turtleneck very
Steve Jobs I'm here he is
hello Jim Gaffigan yes but the iewk like
Steve Jobs tonight I like your toast I
am like Steve Jobs and you guys have
streets well we knew you were coming you
guys have everything King I did an event
for Xfinity for the Comcast family a
corporate event on Monday rich yeah we
do sure how are you doing what are you
doing here at the CMA Awards I have to
know do you like country music I'm
nominated for best female artist and I'm
actually presenting with Blanco all
right there
that's a cool we're presenting a Best
New Artist
so the champagne bottle what's that all
about well it's our show is called the
morning toast but it's actually a dry
red carpet so we brought a bunch of
alcohol and they want to let us open it
so this is merely a problem yeah would
you like to take it with you no I'm okay
I'm worried about you guys why are you
two take care of yourselves don't overdo
it
do we look like we're not taking you're
watching our feed I've been think
everyone's been watching I think so too
hang out there's so many do you like
presenting I feel like you wouldn't like
reading off a teleprompter
no I like it because I kind of just kind
of wing it a little bit yeah and it's
just short and sweet and you're done
yeah and sometimes they give you a gift
afterwards there's a gift yet I don't
think there's a gift I don't know you've
presented at the Grammys right Hannah
yeah was a gift there
there was a whole like bagger stuff
really food ya know like well some of
its makeup which is perfect for you yeah
we guys both on the plane it just means
I mentioned older sister doing shows in
Milwaukee
she took your your baby sister yeah I
took the register but we just watched
your latest Netflix special it was
[ __ ] hilarious the size after
extra-large is killing yourself that was
so funny like I loved all your fat jokes
like Isabella fat person like it's just
it's too good I know your publicist only
said one question and I know you're
staring at me so we react we respect to
time to time I'm excited for the pale
tourists there you go also follow me
back on Instagram
oh yeah it's hard to pull off a hat here
but like if anywhere is GMA oh this is
my first hat how am I gonna you're doing
good you know it's more of like a it's a
way you carry yourself than anything
exactly accomplished she told me she was
are here obviously because who wouldn't
want to be but you're also in a music
video for a famous which is such a good
song and I'm not gonna lie when I was
watching it I was thinking like why were
you the celebrity and you were the
person working on set that first cuz you
like you're like cuz you're like a star
like the way you look like you should
have been the celeb just should have
been the PA I'm not gonna lie no I think
I think it worked out great you it was
great a better job than I probably would
have done is it onon like pretending
like you don't know each other even
though like your data you can't like
acting
it was so hard because we kept like
laughing in between testing like anytime
I went to be serious I would just be
goofy or like hit on her and say
something like overdramatic filming it
like it was so different for us too at
the same time like yes we knew the
cameras where they're sort of likely the
show right but it was so such a
different twist for us okay now I think
the main thing
oh my god it's rusty dick your wife was
here two hours ago what's taking you so
long
yeah we love you talk to you about but
we're talking to them at the Underwood's
right now the future under way how does
one how does one become just like the
start of a music video how does that
process happen do you guys reach out
today to our music video yeah I tagged
them we tagged Adam on an Instagram
story when we were in Denver it was and
it just randomly happened the song just
came out and it was on this it was on
the highway and we had no clue what it
was and we like we're like we promise
we'll learn the lyrics we think this is
going to be amazing
and we played it like 10-15 times that
weekend and then next thing you know
we're coming out to Nashville to see
honestly to dream glowing on The
Bachelor and then getting a [ __ ]
music video like it's so unfair for the
stars I mean in these video so would you
guys like some candy before you go like
I feel like if I was there and like with
all the celebrities like I wouldn't want
bad breath yeah skittles what's your
favorite color
I just don't think skittles are that
good controversial color is handful you
know multi I have to do one time and
flavor like red red purple purple is the
word attention meanie oh I have to pay
attention but M&Ms are you like they all
taste the same but skittles is different
because you can it's really like a
science I didn't show that's gonna be
late have fun it was gonna see you guys
kicking the cake was so funny it was so
so funny and there was a backup cake
which makes it okay yeah but just water
sad sad for the loss of the cake like I
hate I hate the thought of painting
rusty rusty Nick Wow
rusty I just seen you in like again so
glad it's not so good no no come between
us nothing you're come between us except
for everything okay I've juiced I have
two things to tell you one I'm really
happy for
that your song is number one on country
radio that's a really big deal yeah but
at the same time it's like I know you
have like so many fans now more like
bandwagon or it's like I've been your
fan for a long time like the songs I'm
I'm like [ __ ] I know three years ago
but I'm ready for some music rusty you
you hit me up on snapchat like from the
from the premiere of song with her
wedding song yes we not forget yes which
was what three years ago it's a part for
me like for all these bandwagon fans
like who like love you so much sounds
like I was there first yes you were and
I'm really ready for another and I'm
always here for you early next year okay
yeah I know and it's been a long time
yeah it takes takes a long time for
these songs to get to number one thank
you but yeah we're moving on so every
little thing is number one did blue
tacoma go number one and so did yours
obviously yeah three in a row
that's all from one album thank you
that's crazy your wife looks stunning
your wife looks doesn't she look amazing
you guys look amazing
yeah come on she's just running around
here with her red lipstick like to find
that annoying when she wears red
lipstick like can't make out in the car
yeah yeah it's horrible it's horrible do
you find it annoying also when I call
you every time your songs on the radio
no I said just talking to and read like
the other day but you didn't paint on me
because I just called you in the burn
like I thought it would be a lot you
know but I just I'm proud of you like in
New York it's a big deal there's only
one country radio station a ship em and
it's like a little staticky so it was
really big deal it was but not for you
because you like your songs always know
what else isn't annoying all the amazing
toasters that come to my shows do I call
you rusty baby like rusty day they're
like is it no I love it if you guys
don't know in high sin middle school
Russell was bullied and they used to
call him rusty dick and he made the huge
mistake of telling me that because now
it's the only thing I call him and all
the twisters called like they literally
make signs at his show and they say
rusty dick on them but honestly I think
it's a great name I do too
it's like it's empowering like you're
taking the power back from your bully
you take your past pain and you turn it
into profit I just want to kill us
because it's time for you to go the show
starts in like literally nine minutes
have fun
I love you guys so much
we'll see you later can I come back to
the toes anytime you never come to New
York
I really never do okay all right bye I
love you guys so much we say we miss her
someone screenshots also um Hannah Brown
is here in her wedding dress like I just
wait can you look over there oh no it's
a full wedding she's giving her
apologies because she can't shine yeah
then I'm commencement hammer on her
wedding dress oh she's gone she's gone
she should really want to get away from
us I feel like is it over it's closing
6:51 liaison would be found that's so
sad I really want he that's okay today
obviously went out the back door but
there's just no recap and we just got
like banging gas after gas like the last
30 minutes yeah there were so many
people like I can't believe Cal State
came over like she really when you think
about like the grand scheme of like
country music in mainstream media like
she's I would say one of the most famous
country singers yes and you may like
cross her and Kacey Musgraves yeah
really so cute like we're in such
[ __ ] cuz we call them like cheesy
but they're actually like really nice
and I feel like a [ __ ] but they
actually looked so pretty
but the Hat wasn't for me he has really
nice to you there are a lot of major
hats here oh my god this is mr. hat
central this is mr. hat central um wow
you guys thank you so much for watching
I love Jake yes we need him um Jake oh
and snack
Owen snacky Owen yeah he's so hot he
really is so hot and by the way talking
about the first he wrote and we can talk
to you about performing but also he
wrote the verse for Mason Ramsay oh my
god if you ain't got no giddy up and
giddy got my way and by the way and
there was like a lot of controversy
about it because like he didn't get
proper credit because it was Mason
Ramsay and just when it's like Mason
Ramsay we've had him we've at him I they
said raid in an atom I'm like sure
they're a man oh that's it oh he's
handsome oh yeah but he grew his hair
out terrifies him um I just want to say
he's like really cute like not that
famous said he should be ignoring us
okay yeah but you know what the show is
about to start
Oh like literally people are packing up
their [ __ ] yeah like a later time I
don't need anyone
I just saw Keith Urban and and Nicole
Kidman like what just got to the carpet
so they're gonna have to just walk this
way to get inside and they're gonna be
late for the show maybe we could just
turn our camera and just like stand
there while I stand by the door like
we're the correspond and so like you
might exist so that you guys can just
see them like I maybe they won't talk to
us but can we go on the move
actually yeah let's spend so much space
yeah let's wait there's some people
coming who's on oh it's a bunch of
nobodies
the show is actually over but you know
I'm not gonna let it be over like I
don't want we actually do have tickets
for the award show oh yeah okay hold on
walk outside no who's that yeah nobody
okay I think we should wrap it up
everybody is worth it's it's important
you know by the inference important but
you are either a nobody or you're
somebody here that's all I'm saying no
but I think if you're here you're
somebody even though like we don't know
you like you could be a songwriter you
could have written our favorite song in
the world and changed our life that's
true yes sure someone wrote the song the
climb and it wasn't Miley Cyrus and like
that person changed my life we should
meet them yeah we should have them on
the toes I think it's time that we let
the dream die really but what it's like
we go down and then Nicole Kidman comes
is did you see anyone it's hard to tell
yeah it's like it's a u-shape yeah um
yeah I'm definitely feeling like it's
over like people are packing up their
things will end we're gonna wrap at 7
o'clock sharp so you guys can go
straight to the show make sure you now
watch the CMAs on ABC everyone that we
were talking to with like candy in their
pockets and a smile on their face candy
in their pockets thank you all for
tuning in we had a good time it's so
crazy because I kept saying like I was
excited for this to be over because it
makes me so nervous but like I don't
want to end I'm sad another year in the
bucket another great CMA Award show
thank you so much - Xfinity for
partnering with us we love that you
appreciate premium premium content cuz
like we do - and we love you guys hope
you've enjoyed this tree make sure to
follow the morning toast on Instagram
Facebook Twitter
everywhere follow us on Instagram I'm
girl with no job Jackie oh problems we
love you guys and we will see you
tomorrow morning for our podcast right
and no we will see once a day because we
are traveling home tomorrow please pray
that we do not get diverted
love you guys have a great night and
tried the CMA Awards